e
e e
all right so
um ored here all right so uh welcome
good morning happy Pi Day
um that's it is 314 yes
3.14 56 98 never mind um so uh welcome
to the house election law subcommittee
on voter registration and impacts of
non-resident voting um representative C
would you mind leading Us in the
pledge pledge alance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all all right well we have a full Quorum
here today thanks everyone um this is
our fourth meeting I believe and uh I
just want to take time to say I
appreciate everyone uh having made the
effort and uh contributed to the
subcommittee this will probably be our
last uh official subcommittee meeting
there may be some offline work regarding
a
report uh to present to the larger
election law committee but in terms of a
formal working session uh this will
probably be it I
think yes sir uh Mr chairman I think we
have to have a uh formal meeting to
approve the report ah okay so then I
think that's a one of the niceties that
they want okay then then we
will
um we will have
a let's so let's take a moment and
discuss that
our we had a lot of extra time there are
there are several options that present
themselves I
think um
we were able in the
Fuller election law committee able to
make our way through a number of bills
last week at a faster Pace than it
expected I think that's possible for a
number of bills would the sub would
people be available for after the
election law committee meeting for a
meeting to discuss the subcommittee
report
does it make sense to go before so that
the bills could be discussed with a full
committee based on a report that's
adopted or
not right that doesn't give us much time
to do the report do we need to do the
report
before because I'm I'm thinking we might
could do like a verbal one and then
do I I just don't know that we have to
have the written one to the full
committee right by Tuesday or whatever I
don't I don't know what the rules are so
logistic logistically just thinking this
through a little bit the the the thing
that we would need to do is that any
proposed amendments to
the bills before us would need to be
ready by Tuesday for the executive
session of the election law commiss
committee with regard to the report
itself
um I do believe that we could issue it
afterwards
we this subcommittee being familiar with
all the discussions could make the
necessary
amendments to bills as we see fit and
then uh have that we could
I think perhaps give a verbal report I
like that idea
of I just don't know that
we'll I don't I don't know that we'll
have time to complete a report and
discuss it and all that beforehand
um but to answer your question oh I'm
sorry no that's okay I and I know like
on the side I was just going to
recommend that you know we could we're
not meeting till 10 a.m. on Tuesday if
we met at 9: like today on Tuesday if we
had to have anything finalized before we
go into our session perhaps that might
be something we can
entertain if you think that's enough
time to at least kind of have some type
of agreement and
report I was just going to say um that
yes to answer your first question I am
available after Tuesday although after
what do we got 20 bills 21 I I can't
remember the number that's on the list
yeah we we might
be but I like uh representative
Burnham's idea
maybe at nine I can do that too but I
live five miles away so I don't want to
speak for anybody who's going to drive
more than 10
minutes would noticing be an issue at
all I I don't know the rules on that we
could notice for 9:00 on Tuesday we
could meet for an hour and then we could
recess and then continue the meeting
afterwards as
necessary that day I
suppose
um again I I really appreciate
everybody's efforts to help bring this
across the finish line that that's a
long day on Tuesday but that may prepare
us for Thursday so
uh so that should be that yes
representative C I'm just looking at the
calendar and U Thursday
March
um I'm sorry Thursday April 3rd is the
last day to report all remaining HBS and
I'm not sure whether this list for next
Tuesday is the final list or whether we
have one more executive session
are those are those second committee
bills uh some of them are FN so they
would be and the no but I meant that
date is that for second committee bills
or is that for but that's for all bills
the last day to act
on um House Bill oh I'm
sorry Thursday March 27th is the last
day to act on house bills not in a
second committee that's in that's
crossover date right so so crossover is
April 10th but they have to be acted on
by the Full House right
so theoretically so what that was the
27th yes so theoretically we
could it's possible we could do
something on the uh Tuesday
before
okay um
18th
actually this one probably is our last
the 18 is probably our last one because
the other would only be 3 days before um
the deadline which is not enough time to
notice right my understanding is that's
everything because um uh the chair asked
me to give him a list of what I thought
we had left and I probably asked
representative Burnham too and then I
think um our assistant Robin Bach also
gave him a list so I think that's how he
put that together trying to capture
everything that we had left now we have
already exec a couple of the bills were
on the subcommittee list
yep no that's okay all right well I
think so I I
I think it's up to us to try and adopt
uh any amendments we can do that
individually uh we don't have to do that
as a
subcommittee uh based on what we've
learned from here but I
um I did want to do a couple of things
oh first I just want to always uh I
forget this sometimes so I want to read
the mission statement was um at the
direction of the chairman of the
election law committee this bipartisan
subcommittee is tasked with evaluating
consolidating and reconciling various
2025 house bills concerning voter
registration and the impacts of
non-resident voting accordingly the
subcommittee will review the proposed
legislation with attention to
constitutionality any necessary
alignment with federal election law and
legal
precedence the subcommittee will
consider historical context and
opportunities to clarify current
regulations the subcommittee will issue
a report to summarize its findings
conclusions and
recommendations all right so
um what I'd like to do is uh
representative Lane if you could uh
speak to your bill briefly I'd like to
to speak
to uh House Bill 289 at some
point
and uh communicate some information that
was uh provided to us um outside of
the uh meeting of the subcommittee and
then I'd like to go over
uh uh some discussion this discussion
points paper that I've presented so if
you would are ready to go ahead please
do so um thank you um so uh this is uh
HB
385 and um I do have an amendment but
it's not all that uh and I handed out
last week what I was trying to get as an
amendment and marked up the sheet so but
the goal of the bill was to essentially
overturn uh HB 1569
and put us back where we were before
that bill was passed and so uh what I
did if you look in your purple book b
and I didn't do all of the OS was mostly
but they did a great job um it was to go
back to what's in our purple book so I
know it looks really long but 1569 was a
big Bill itself and kind of completely
over um um you know overhaul the bill so
in order to put it back the way it was
um that's why the Bill's so long and
that's I mean I can go through it Page
by page if you want but that that is the
goal and uh I don't think we need to
take a vote that the subcommittee does
not want you to do that right I I I
can't imagine that you would but um you
know I just made that lovely offer and
um so I have copies of the full
amendment I did get them back that from
OSS and I can pass those around and I
have them ready for Tuesday and um so
there we um have that so um so that's
the that's the short version I'll go
longer if you want
but uh no no I see uh I see we have the
honor of Representative Lynn joining us
did did you want to speak to us today or
you just listening in apologize
iot yeah
yeah oh I need
here oh thank you um did these are the
one two one two three those are that's
the full Amendment okay without the
markup all right thank you which I can
give you again but I'd have to go
upstairs to make get copies right right
right um okay but I gave last week last
week and so I I did because the chair
asked me to go through and um compare it
and see if I miss anything and so the
changes that are on page 17 and 18 those
were the changes that when I compared it
so okay so that's it did you know that
your bill is actually longer than 156
yes I know because putting everything
back in putting everything back in made
it longer but yeah all right uh very
good so um all right so
what uh what I'd like to do right now
too is just
um
discuss one bill that is mine actually
and just explain some concerns that have
been brought to my
attention uh last week when we
were uh meeting we did not have a full
Quorum but
the and so we the the subcommittee did
not
uh formally meet during that time when
we were waiting for a full Quorum but uh
outside of the
subcommittee there was some testimony
from Mr Clement totz and Mr
O'Brien uh regarding uh House Bill
289 and I'll just relay a couple aspects
of that and then I'd like to get into
the discussion points paper that I've
distributed to the subcommittee here so
uh Mr Clement totz of the ACLU noted
that so House Bill excuse me House Bill
289 is regarding domicile qualifications
for voting and make some changes
to the uh RSA 651
654 colon 1 Roman numeral 1 and 1
a and had some statements about
uh domicile being claimed if a person is
a legal dependent under custody at
address at an address outside the state
of New
Hampshire and then also add some
residency rules as established by the
University of system of New Hampshire
and Mr Clement totz made note that from
a uh couple of perspectives that
the uh tax perspective is not under the
control of the voter
necessarily and there was some concerns
about the confidential confidentiality
of tax returns how would this be
enforced um H how there there's no
payments being made to New Hampshire
therefore New Hampshire does New
Hampshire have a right to those tax
returns and those sorts of
things uh and
taxes uh perhaps not always uh proof of
physical presence but um and even the
tax law allows for temporary absences
due
to uh
student um requirements
so there is there are those aspects that
he communicated so he he thought the the
aspect of a legal legal dependent under
custody at an address outside the state
of New
Hampshire had issues with it both from
sort of a uh privacy aspect a
enforcement aspect and just uh
constitutional aspect because it's not
under the control of the voter whether
or not um a person were were to claim
that and then Mr O'Brien made note that
the university system of new Hampshire
establishes residency based
on or establishes residency at the time
of application is that did um actually I
you just Mr O'Brien just walked in so
I'll um if you wish to come up and uh
specify that again as a formal testimony
Mr O'Brien that would be
great sure thank you Mr chair uh I'm
going have to find the actually you real
quick but my name is michaeel Brian uh
with strategies representing my client
America votes um and on the UNH website
um as it talks about in state tuition um
the first sentence is residency is
determined at the time of admission for
degree students um and
so again uh tying in situation to voting
um I could you know be in I could rent
an apartment right in New Market uh for
four years but if you tie qualification
uh to instate tuition uh I wouldn't
qualify if I didn't necessarily you know
if I um because at the time of admission
and that there's that's actually a
problem right if I live and rent a place
for four years maybe that turns into six
years who knows but I'm I am eligible to
vote right like that is very clear um
and then their admission standards this
goes back to the same conversation that
Mr Clement totz uh had brought up which
is to say um the sentence that it
continues to read uh to qualify for
instate tuition status a student and or
his or or her parents if a dependent
must physically reside in New Hampshire
and so this again is tying someone it
ties your right to vote to someone
else's ability to claim you as a
dependent um and that is problematic for
a lot of reasons again as was State m
cloi i my right to vote is mine I can't
control if my necessarily if my parents
claim me as a dependent if they don't um
you know that's a decision for them not
a decision for me but um that is not how
we determine voting laws for good reason
right obviously you get very messy if
someone else could determine where you
were able to vote um and probably a lot
of us wouldn't like that very much uh
and so uh that is you know it's right
off their website where I pulled this
from um but the the rules for being in
state tuition in un are far stricter um
for for uh for them than it is what our
rules to register to vote are or would
be allowed so
uh thank you very much are there any
questions from the
subcommittee representative Lane I don't
really have a question per se but I
recall that we had somebody here from
UNH their lobbyists and I think she
testified in much of the same vein that
you did do you were you here when she
was here and I can't even remember what
I can barely remember yesterday at this
point uh so uh I don't I'm not sure what
I will say is I and I said this to uh
the chair uh last week um you know I
have I think I said committee this is my
I think 12th or 13th year in front of
the election law committee uh in in this
uh in the house um through through my
work and I have seen a version of this
uh Bill uh a number of times uh and
there was actually one in the Senate
earlier this year too and I don't want
to be very clear that I do not represent
the the university system I have no no
ties to them and so but I do know from
hearing this you know one of obviously
the concerns is um that if uh a student
received inate tuition solely because
they registered to vote and not based on
the rules it would cost the university
system I mean it would it would bankrupt
the university system it feels like I'm
not going to again I'm not speaking for
them and I want to be very clear um but
it would certainly be a huge cost um to
the state so um that's a a separate
issue but it is tied and I I'm sure that
came up in their testimony
20 no thank you thank you and uh anyone
interested in that can look for the
testimony for the Senate bill to to find
out the pertinent facts of that that was
uh it was Comm testified and the amount
was discussed it was quite High um so
okay
um seeing no other questions thank you
very much Mr BR thank you and I'll be
here for all right
great all right at this point um I'd
like
to uh go over a a a
a paper it's a four-page paper for those
who are looking in here that that I've
labeled discussion
points and it's it's my attempt at
really trying to consolidate all the
information that we've heard as well as
a number of the court cases that have
been identified by our researcher Mr
Allen
and trying to uh put all this together
as best I
could uh for the subcommittee's review
so let me just give a broad introduction
to it
uh and and
then I apologize we don't have any any
other copies available um suppose we
could get some more made if people are
interested but
um so what I sort of identified
from the court cases the the research
that's been done the testimonies that
we've had is that there are really
four four if you will main issues
and the first one is is proof of
citizenship uh I'll just introduce them
at a high level first and then go into
detail on all of them the second one is
the standards for
identification the third one is
non-resident voting or vote non-resident
voting and then the fourth one is really
absentee ballot applications and and
just to
to uh I might refine those titles a
little bit later um for the final report
but uh basically what I've done is I've
outlined
a series of of aspects of each
issue uh identifying it as a problem
statement what are the adverse impacts
what is the proposed solution what are
the proposed
changes and then what are the RS essays
that need to be changed and then what's
the supporting legislation or legal
cases and there might be some other
information on the form as well
depending upon the
topic for proof of
citizenship uh the current RSA requires
documented proof of citizenship for
registration
and to some extent that is New
Hampshire's
absolute right as a sovereign uh State
here is that we can require that only US
citizens or and this is this is law only
US citizens can vote in federal
elections there's a court case about
that very
specifically and New Hampshire has a
right to restrict voting in state and
local elections to US
citizens however per the national voter
Rights Act from 1993 in the rules of the
election assistance committee only and
I'm quoting here the applicant signature
attesting under penalty of perjury that
the applicant is a United States citizen
is required for federal elections
so they don't have four Federal
elections in order to comply with the
national voter Rights
Act an applicant does not necessarily
need at that
moment a documented proof of
citizenship um
so that makes that the only
qualification where an applicant May
self attest to a
qualification but for the purposes of
federal election so that that self
attestation has to be accepted by New
Hampshire for federal elections per the
national voter Rights
Act um so so what's the adverse impact
um New Hampshire must allow signature
attestation for federal
elections um the defend of proof of
citizenship does not have to be provided
on Election
Day and so for federal elections some
voters will not have provided full
documented proof of their citizenship
qualification
um so how how do we how do we deal with
that my so this is what I'm
proposing is that we sort of establish
fully qualified voters and provisionally
qualified voters Prov fully qualified
voters will have provided all documented
or will have provided documented proof
for all the qualified voter
criteria a provisionally qualified
voter will not have provided all the
documented proof required to be fully
qualified um
and applicants must provide document
identification for
registration
uh and if they don't have
that
um at least for federal elections I
think we have to minimally provide a
provisional ballot of some sort for that
election and if app applicants do not
provide sufficient documented proof of
their
qualifications
afterwards they would be removed from
the voter
checklist
so provisionally qualified voters May
attest for the voter qualification of
citizenship for a federal
election and and I would propose that
voters to self- attest citizenship in
federal elections are permitted to vote
by federal only
ballot that is a practice in a a number
of states
um representative Lynn did you want to
make a comment to the subcommittee
please you're welcome to do so we we
would welcome your Sage
advice I'm not sure how Sage it is but I
guess what I would say is I I think and
I certainly stand to be
corrected I think that we're not subject
to the National vote we're ex we're we
are we are not covered by that as I
understand it because I mean one of
the that's C candidly that's one of the
the foundations of uh 1569 that we
passed last year if we you know I'm I'm
well aware that states that are subject
to the National voter registration act
for citizenship that there's that case
that says
a Supreme Court case it says if you sign
you know it's good enough to just sign
the affidavit
but as I understand it we are not we we
are one of I'm not sure how many states
I I knew at one point but I've forgotten
there are a few States including New
Hampshire that are not subject to that
are exempt from and so I think that it's
it's based on that based on the fact
that we are not subject to the National
voter registration act we are not
subject to that
requirement of you know that the only
way you could that it's sufficient to
prove C US citizenship to just sign the
affidavit it um if if I if I may ask a
couple of questions of you are you are
are you uh willing to take a few
questions or at least raise some
comments here sure I no I me I I didn't
I didn't expect to be doing this but I'm
happy to I'm happy to try sure I I I
appreciate the ad hoc participation so
uh very very much
appreciated um so certainly the uh
National voter Rights Act from 1993 has
certain requirements um the the
most the the requirement that most
people are familiar with is what they
call the Motor Voter aspects where you
are automatically registered to to vote
vote with your application for a
driver's
license to my
understanding that part as as you
correctly said does not apply to New
Hampshire because we had conditions
already in place and we have uh
registration on Election Day and
therefore um those conditions allow us
to
exclude ourselves
from the Motor Voter aspects of the
national voter rights
act however I and again I I stand to be
corrected if I if um if you want to do
some research over the weekend uh is
that it's it's my understanding that
because there are uh Federal elections
aspects in the National voter rights act
that uh do not
require it's this aspect of citizenship
you don't require documented proof you
can just sign off and that that aspect
might still apply that's that's what
my
um and
and that you know maybe I've divided the
question here but inappropriately but I
think that's my understanding
from
uh looking at is that aspect would still
apply to us I could be wrong about that
so you know I I guess what I would you
know I I as I said if I if I had you
know if I had known we were gonna have
this discussion I would have but my I
thought that the excl usion that there
was a section of the national voter
registration act that
said this act doesn't apply
to you know or or these states or
something like that this act doesn't
apply to these states I as I recall and
again I wish I hadn't I don't think that
it said like that it
said you know sections one and two and
three or something of this act don't
apply I thought it just said this act
okay so I I understood that to
mean
that you know this that the national
voter registration act simply didn't it
didn't apply to um to the the states
that were exempt um but I again I wish
um you know I wish that I had um I wish
I had something in here in front of me
um to to and I guess you know and I I
have to say I if I mean I have if the
national voter if if the part of the
national voter registration act that
says you can um you can satisfy
citizenship by signing an affidavit if
that applies to New Hampshire then then
I mean I have to say 1569 is unconstitu
U I don't think if if because it says
you have to provide documentation and
and at least as to Federal elections I
think I'd have to concede that it was
unconstitutional but I I don't think
that that's the case and I guess I would
I would have
thought that
if if that was the
case during the debate because you know
1569 was hotly contested I would have
thought thought that during the debate
on
1569 somebody Mr Mr Clem Clement wit
from the ACLU or somebody that opposed
it would have said wait a minute this I
and I know they made various arguments
that the law would be unconstitutional I
understand that and I understand there's
a LW but I don't ever recall them saying
wait a minute you can't do this because
the the we're not exempt from the
national voter registration act as to
this provision if they had said that
that would have been I mean that that
case the case over I cuz I would you
know concede that that's that if if if
the requirement that you can you know um
you can satisfy citizenship by an
affidavit applies to New Hampshire under
the national voter registration act then
at least for federal elections we don't
have any choice we have to comply with
that I I as I say I don't think that
that's right and I think that if the
opponents of 1569 had such a slam duck
Dunk argument for why they why it was
unconstitutional they would have made it
and I don't recall ever hearing that
argument so I think that that may not be
the
case uh than thank you very much yes I'm
sorry uh representative
Lane thank you and thank you for taking
my question sure um having been one of
those opponents uh we did raise a
concern about the this this act and
we're afraid that it would in fact take
away that 1569 would take away the
granting of the exception that we have
from the national voter reg Rights Act
and that because of that uh we would
then fall into the requirements of
national of the act and we were
concerned because the state worked so
hard to get the exemption um that then
we would be in the Motor Voter act and
we would be falling into this and we ask
for an opinion but we're never given it
but but I'm sorry respectfully
representative that's a different
argument that that is a different
argument I and I don't disagree with you
you did make that you did make that
point but that's that's not an argument
that the act the national voter
registration act applies to us right now
as to this provision and and therefore
you can't do this that's like saying
well some other provision um you're
you're basically if I understood the
argument and I think I did it was you
are
making um you are
making it so honorous to register on
Election Day to have election day
registration that in fact in in effect
there's no longer any same day
registration because you've made it too
honorous and therefore if if a court
were to conclude that they might say
well that means that you don't have you
know longer effectively have same day
registration and therefore the
conditions of your exemption don't apply
that I you know is that an argument yeah
it's an argument maybe you'll win it I I
have my my suspicions about whe that
that may not Prevail but I could be
wrong but that's a different argument
than the one I'm talking about I know
but we did raise this act I all I was
trying to say is we did raise concerns
about this act and had asked for or some
guidance um and it we never got it from
um from either uh from the AG's office
or from um the sponsors sure sure no I I
hear you all I'm saying is you know if
if if the if the issue that has been
raised by the by the chair here was um
if that were the case I would have
thought that you uh you know or or
somebody else would have said when this
this is crazy why are you even going
forward this the the we're we are
subject to this provision of the
national voter registration act and
therefore you can't do this and that and
and and if they had if that argument had
been made to me I would have said you're
absolutely right you we you know we
can't do this but I I I don't think that
that's
correct representative C thank you for
taking my question uh you had mentioned
uh possibly unconstitutional was that
actually in violation of the
Constitution or uh just not in
compliance with the federal uh Voting
Rights
Act no well I mean it it's there there
sort of a in other words what I was what
I was trying saying a moment ago is
if the section of the national voter
registration act that allows a person to
satisfy the CI the US citizenship
requirement simply by signing an
affidavit if that section applies to New
Hampshire then under the supremacy
clause of the US Constitution we could
not not comply with that at least for
federal elections we could not not
comply with that and if we passed a law
that didn't comply with it it would
violate the supremacy clause of the
Constitution and therefore would be
unconstitutional thank you
representative new thank you um even
assuming we New Hampshire is fully
exempt would it be allowable for us to
basically recreate that Federal only
registration affidavit requirement
within our
laws other words I I think yeah I think
we probably in other words I I suppose
New Hampshire could say even though we
are not subject to the National voter
registration act at all um we are going
to um at least for Fe we're going to
draw a distinction between federal and
state elections and say that for at
least for federal elections or I suppose
you could say you know in terms of if
we're not subject to the law to the
federal law I suppose we could say
either for only Federal elections or
really even for all elections you could
say even though we don't have to do this
this is what we're going to this is what
we're going to do you know for the
reasons that we had the debate on 1569 I
would
say you know I would oppose that I would
say that was a bad idea but you but
could you do that yes the only other
thing I would say is I I would really
strongly suggest this and I I would hope
this might be something there' be
bipartisan uh agreement on I think it
would be a really bad idea even if you
could do this to draw a distinction
between federal and state elections you
know I think that's what a Arizona which
is subject to the National voter
registry that's what they did and if if
you know if you re if you look at what's
going on there there's it's it's it just
seems kind of crazy of having the two
you know the the elections are held on
the same day but some you you get to
vote
for these you know the federal Offices
under one criteria and State offices
under boy I I do not think that's a good
idea and I would hope that you know
there would be bipartisan support on on
not doing that I don't disagree with you
on that um and uh as a new
representative this term I'm not as
familiar with the whole debates on
1569 uh since I wasn't around for that
session but I appreciate the the
viewpoint on all that thank you very
much thank well thank you
well a as you uh correctly stated the
the law does say um I pulled it up and
it does
say
uh Nona there is a section in there
talking about non-applicability to
certain States
and
um uh the first provision is where there
is no vote
registration requirement for any voter
in the
state um and I I think there's one state
that falls under that category one of
the North Dakota perhaps I think yeah
and then the
uh then the second Clause under that is
a state in which under law that is in
effect continuously on or after August
1st 1994 or that was enacted on or prior
to August 1st 1994 and by terms has come
to effect upon the enactment of this act
so long as that law remains in effect
all voters in the state must register to
vote at the polling place at the time of
voting in the general election for
federal office so
um if I if I could ask just when it says
under law that is in that is in effect
continually
um one can still amend the
law you know what I my my recollection
is that what the Congress was concerned
about and I think a legitimate concern
was
um they didn't they didn't want they
were comfortable saying that whatever
the states were that either didn't have
voter registration that W North Dakota
whatever or the states that allowed same
day
registration if
that if if they had a sort of a history
of allowing same day registration as New
Hampshire did um uh as of I I think the
date that's referred to in there is the
date that the national voter
registration act would become effective
um that um those States they wanted to
exemp but I think what they wanted to
avoid is States deciding oh we don't
want to be subject to the new law so
we'll now change our law to allow same
day registration I think that's I I
think that was what they were trying to
get at is if you've already done this
you know for a long period of time fine
we'll exempt you but we're not going to
allow new states to decide to to exempt
themselves by passing new laws so so uh
just to clarify then the aspect that
that is probably talking about is really
the same day regist election day
registration I think that's you know it
was the way you read it it was worded it
it sounds like it was worded maybe a
little awkwardly but I think that's what
it was saying is that same day say uh
you can register on Election Day yeah
that um yes that that sounds correct so
um all
right any other
questions from the subcommittee not at
this point okay thank you thank well
thank you thanks so much appreciate it
again I appreciate the ad hoc uh
impromptu
testimony um Mr O'Brien I see you are
eager to
approach the microphone with some of
these questions as well uh Michael Brian
party strategies with America votes um
so yes we have a full exemption from the
NV so start there um continually does
reference election day registration and
uh Maine for instance
repealed their ele registration shortly
after 2010 I believe they then lost
their exemption from the nvra and then
they put it back but they still can't
get their exemption back so now they
fall under both they have same day but
they also fall under the NV so once you
remove um the ability for every voter to
vote on Election Day um your uh exension
from the NV is immediately either put at
risk or rescinded it has to go I mean
there's a process obviously but that's
part of it um to the federal having two
elections Point agree with
representative that it's a bad idea uh
we'll say we cannot do that we have one
checklist in this state we all of our
our laws govern all of Elections we do
not have like Arizona the ability to
bifurcate our elections and we should
not bifurcate our elections um but as of
right now as we stand we could not say
rules for federal and rules for state
like Arizona does we have one rules for
all of our elections minus of course
Town meetings which we don't classify as
elections right and so um uh and so
there um that is I just want to be very
clear on that that's also not an option
also just briefly you were pointing
about provisional ballots because we had
this debate about 418 a couple of years
ago uh the Constitution says that the
ballots have to be counted at the same
time uh and that's defined as like you
can't like you know even if you're
counting at 6:00 am and you started at
11: pm or 9:00 p.m. or whatever time you
can't you know go home and come back and
finish counting and so provisionals have
always been uh uh deemed to be something
we cannot do here um because of that
because we can't not count someone's
ballot and then turn around five days
later or whatever the case may be Inc
count them so I just want to be clear
with the committee on that as well and
the last thing I'll say is on 1569 and
the law that was passed we just had our
first election on Tuesday uh where this
law was in effect um the campaign for
voting rights um had observed
in I'm going to say 10 to 15 20 spots
across the state um we are aware of 46
voters that were turned away um from
being able to register or be able to
vote um on Tuesday which is really high
for the number of places that we were in
and for the type of election this is
right so town meeting uh day you think
mostly As voters who are you know aren't
you're not getting a lot of new
registrants on town meeting day right
this isn't a presidential election where
there are lots of folks coming in um
including uh a woman from Hampton who
brought both of her kids she also had
her ID she had her birth certificate but
it did not match her uh her uh ma a name
and so she was unable to vote because
her birth cerificate did not match and
so uh because of that she was turned
away um this uh to representative Lane's
point I think does she was not allowed
to register on Election Day does this
put us in violation of NVR of the of our
exemption NV NVR right it might it
certainly I would hope would Len pause
to think about should we be I mean I
don't I don't think it's reasonable to
believe this woman was trying to create
fraud uh commit fraud showing up with
her two kids in all of her documents
except one document that linked her
previous name to her current name that
would be a pretty crazy thing it feels
like for me to do um and so we have now
seen this in what is generally a pretty
small election and it had a pretty
outsized impact um and so just want us
to be aware of that as we think about
moving forward and what we want to try
to do
um you know we obviously have we can
debate Ro of fraud probably the end of
time with I imagine some folks in this
committee but what we do know is that
proof of fraud is pretty limited um and
I would I would without having to Second
think thing about this at all never have
we seen 46 cases of fraud in one
election certainly not in a town meeting
election and we just saw 46 voters
turned away at a town meeting election
um and so as we weigh what is an
outsized impact right I just want us to
be aware and think about that so happy
to glad I was able to hopefully clear
some of those questions up that we had
um and and obviously happy to answer
more if I can but you you are willing to
take a few questions sure of course um
represent thank you um of those 46 cases
how many were women versus men uh I
don't have the data in front of me but
I'm happy to try and see if we have all
of that we just had observers there
right so they were watching they were um
to see and I don't know what their notes
look like to be totally Frank yeah and
that's only those 46 were only where you
had staff correct so there were many
other locations corre that were not
staffed so this n the true total number
could be much higher correct and I would
expect that it would be okay and and we
said this before but what we saw in
Kansas when they did the proof of
citizenship as as a requirement was
about 30% of Voters in the 2-year span
who registered and I think that's 12,000
voters
were turned away from registering um it
is why the other thing I will say about
this it is not just the court said that
you can't require citizenship a uh um
federal court uh circuit court
because the it is it takes too too long
to get a passport and it is often too
expensive to get a passport so it's not
just cost but also time right um we know
it can take four to six weeks sometimes
longer than that to get your passport
and so if a voter wants to vote and
doesn't have that document it takes them
a long time
when the court looked at that and those
30,000 they the state's own expert who
went through the list to see how many of
those folks were citizens found that
over 99.9% of them work and so they
turned away 30,000 voters almost all of
whom by the state's own expert of that
law said yeah these were citizens and
they should have been allowed to vote
and so and that tracks with the reason I
bring that up is because that tracks
with the numbers that we saw on Tuesday
where you're not having a ton of folks
register right again it's a town meeting
day this is not same day registration is
not super high on this day but you would
see of eight people who attempted to
register two of them were turned away of
seven who attempted to register three of
them were turned away we pretty
consistently fell and that 25 to 30% of
people turned away which is totally in
line with what we saw in Kansas when
Kansas passed uh a similar although
actually less stringent law than what we
solved with 1569 and so um I'm not
totally surprised by those numbers um
they are in line with what historically
we would expect based on other states
who have tried this
do you know if all of those uh
individuals were turned away simply for
the qualification of citizenship I do
not know again I do know that two were
turned away because they didn't have
their ID on them to vote so of the 46 I
know that 44 of them were turned away
because they lacked a registration
document I do not know if it was
strictly citizenship or if there was
another document they were missing again
I can try to get that for this committee
if we have it I am not
aware and I don't want to mislead
certainly so
right so they these are individuals who
had not been previously reg or two of
those individuals were individuals who
had not been previously registered and
they had no identity papers no so those
two that I'm referencing sorry are
previously registered voters who showed
up and did not have their ID on them um
to to vote so they were on the roles
previously obviously I could have signed
the affidavit I would have had my
picture taken I would have gone through
that whole thing um and as someone who
has shown up once to the polls without
their ID on them um I sympathize with
that um I'm happy to it's always an
embarrassing story but driving back from
the peterb players to francistown New
Hampshire as you imagine it's a lot of
back roads and a lot of uh a lot of
darkness and I took the wrong turn and
then made a u-turn on the on the road
that I was on because I needed to go
back and all of a sudden flashing lights
were behind me uh the cop I think
expected to find a drunk teenager but
found uh a you know a dad uh with his
wife who just returned from a show I
explained he he let me go I put my
license in my jacket pocket that I was
wearing because I was going to see a
show and so I dressed up a little bit
that was a Sunday on Tuesday I went to
go vote pulled out my wallet my ID
wasn't there right uh I got my picture
taken I went through the process I did
all of that um that's the voter we're
talking about they showed up they pulled
out their you know wallet whatever um
and they did not have their ID on them
and they were told they were not allowed
to vote so those are previously
registered folks but who who no longer
could sign the affidavit due to the
law okay
and and
you're are you claiming that
providing identification is a burden I'm
not I'm I'm ask I'm just telling the
committee what we saw on Tuesday um and
asking the committee just to think about
as we move forward whatever
recommendation come from the sub
commmittee the full committee
that when you pass laws that affect
folks you know rights to vote
right that the consequence of that can
sometimes and this is a I think this is
just part of the overall discussion that
is had right is and I think what Mr
Clement to said right is what is what is
the cost versus the
benefit and so I'm not saying that you
know we shouldn't have laws and people
should just be able to you know do
whatever they want to do but I am saying
to think about for instance with all
these absente te voter bills that we're
seeing
right if there is a voter who is
Homebound and we heard this from
disability Community right that there
are voters who use affidavit ballots
because they struggle to be able to get
to a clerk's office or leave their house
or do the things they need to do if we
are uh affecting their right to vote
what is the counterbalance to that and
is is that is taking the vote away from
a duly legitimate voter right is that
being made up for by whatever law that
you're passing and I would just say
again 46 voters in a town meeting
election or 44 to register is just I
mean the number I expected totally
honest I thought we see five maybe 10
for the type of election that this is 44
46 that we know of again has it blew me
away that the number was that high and I
just think it again it shows what is
the the impact appears greater than what
we were trying to solve because we know
the affidavits were never producing
those kind of numbers right occasionally
you would catch a person who committed
fraud and they were then prosecuted for
that act but we never saw 46 in an
election or anywhere close to that right
I bet in the last 20 elections we didn't
see 46 and so Impact versus what you are
you know purporting to try to stop I
think it's just an important thing to
keep in mind as we as we move forward
yeah I I don't think we yet know the
nature of those 46 cases so we don't
know if they lack of proof of
citizenship or yeah all we know is they
were turned away right they showed up
and were told no you were not allowed to
vote right so I
think so if they were not able to
prove uh domicile if they were not able
ble to prove citizenship if they were
somehow not able to provide their
Identity or their age then those are the
voter qualifications cor so if if any of
those criteria were not met they would
have been turned away correct y so um
okay so I
think
um while the caution is is heard and
well advised I think we also need to
make sure that we understand exactly why
these individuals were turned away and
what what the situation
was
um okay well thank you very
much all
right Mr chair yes I just want to point
out that when uh
Secretary of State uh testified I can't
remember if it was on 1569 or 1370 I
kind of get them confused sometimes but
he said that removing qualified voter
affidavits for citizenship would affect
tens of thousands of New Hampshire
voters who could not otherwise be
quickly verified as being previously
registered through the centralized voter
day base so yes we need to wait to see
I I agree on those 44 before we rely on
that but we also have testimony from
secet state from a year ago that he knew
that it would affect tens of thousands
of people when if they put in the
citizenship
qualification just that's all I'm
saying
well I just want us to remember that
that he said that it's it's a good point
um
um I um and granted it was a local
election I'm not sure that 46 or
whatever the number is uh amounts to
tens of thousands
yet but that was a general so um
usually um there's my my experience is
that there's
a 4:1 turnout ratio for or maybe 3 to
one sometimes
for um General versus a local election
so if
uh we ended up
getting more
uh it's still I don't I don't know that
we're hitting that tens of thousands
threshold quite yet but not that that's
a I didn't expect that we would on town
meeting day I right not that that's not
that that sort of threshold is
acceptable but I think what's important
is that we we need to understand why
these people were turned away and um
you know we always have to
balance um we always have to
balance uh the necessity to
conduct our elections in a manner that
provides confidence to the voters that
we're conducting it with integrity and
that we're doing the necessary steps to
prevent or mitigate potential fraud and
I I I people often bring up the question
about fraud and I think the the the
greatest problem with fraud is that it
is fraud you it's U they're uh trying to
deceive I think
what's most easily prosecutable and that
we see the AG constantly doing is those
individuals who choose to vote in two
places
are EAS are most easily caught so one of
the aspects of
of of this whole fraud fraud discussion
is
detectability and a someone who votes in
two places has increased the likelihood
of the detectability of Fraud and I
think that's that's the nature
of uh some of the aspects of why why we
don't see perhaps larger aspects of
fraud uh being uh
discovered all right so
[Music]
um m m yes I understand that we you're
never going to have a system that is
100% just because it's human and we're
all human and if somebody really really
wants to commit fraud they will find a
way to do it
so I think we just need to be careful
that we don't take a sledgehammer and
disenfranchise tens of thousands of
people because we think maybe 10 15 44
people are going to sneak through and
and do it because it is the right to
vote and there is a balancing act and we
just need to be thoughtful about how far
are we going to go to exclude people in
order to maybe prevent those other 44
people from voting I don't know but I
just think we need to all keep that in
mind when we go through all of these
bills you know what what are we trying
to to do and is it really in the best
interest of the state to disenfranchise
people well I um I
I I I think this the state does not have
a any interest in disfranchising people
but I do think the state has obligations
to make sure that the uh elections are
are held with Integrity so and and to
not
create anything that is overly
burdensome for voters but
um I mean that certainly cases like
Crawford versus Marian clearly discussed
that so
um all
right yes representative vernham yes
thank you I just wanted to make a
comment so I had the privilege to work
on Tuesday as a ballot Clerk and in the
short time that I was doing that uh we
had two uh voters that came they were
new new residents of the town and
showed their driver's license
Unfortunately they weren't on the list
so they were told that they needed to go
um and give um additional information to
the supervisor of the
checklist uh one of the two I believe
had to go home to get that information
but in both instances they were fine
they were they wanted to comply to what
the law was they didn't you know have a
problem with that and then they did come
back and they were able to vote so I
think that that is working so that was
just I wanted to just share my actual
experience in my at my table for my
short time that I was able to be there
that the same two people that were
rejected to get their ballot did the
process and then came back even if it
was 45 minutes later they were fine to
to comply so thank
you representative C I was just
wondering if it'd be worth our while to
formulate a couple questions for the
Secretary of State to get us a response
in terms of um the the number of people
who were turned away and he may have to
solicit that information from town
moderators to find out um and
also uh his take on um our exemption to
the uh federal regulations
and maybe some other questions as
well yes thank representative new um I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but your previous statement sounded like
you were saying that you believe that
fraud is in existence in the state and
that the problem is we're just not
catching it in which case wouldn't the
proper solution to that
be providing more funds to the agent 's
office and increasing their fraud their
voter fraud department so that we can
catch those cases that might be out
there rather than cutting the ability to
vote since as representative Lane said a
fraudster is going to be a
fraudster um and then it's a matter of
catching them which the registration
process the voting process won't catch
the people that you're referring to it
would be the later investigations in the
AG's Department would be the way to
solve
that just a
thought yeah I um thank you
representative Newsome I
think I think both the Secretary of
State and the AG's
office
deal I think they deal with if I may two
types of problems that
occur that potentially challenge
election Integrity one is is
non-compliance simply someone is not
following the basic rules in a in a
proper way and you know we see this a
lot with
electioneering aspects or other um down
in Hudson we had uh a number of
questions raised because a private
entity put up
uh electronic signs that appeared to be
very similar to what the town uses and
and several people contacted myself and
another representative who also happens
to be a selectman I'm on the budget
committee but um for that town but um
contacted me and another uh
representative about these signs they
thought there was improper election
heing going on and you know after
investigation um
my fellow representative from Hudson
determined that no in fact it was a
private entity who had hired it and they
were doing everything properly and um we
communicated that to the AG's office and
actually got a response within a day
from uh the infamous Dick Tracy and uh
that was a pleasure getting that uh
email and we were able to you know at
least uh you know alert them that if any
one complained from Hudson this was the
situation going on and this this should
be a low priority because we had already
helped them with a a number of aspects
of what would have been an investigation
so to me
that is is what I would classify as a
non-compliance situation I think they
deal with that probably 90% of the time
I think the fraud is as I said before
the detectability aspects of it
are uh much more challenging in and the
most obvious detectability aspect is
when a person votes in two places
because then whether it's two places in
New Hampshire or as we've seen in recent
prosecutions someone in Massachusetts
and someone in uh New Hampshire so or
somewhere in Massachusetts somewhere in
New Hampshire
um so I I think a lot of their focus and
efforts
is uh you know perhaps
in addressing those aspects and and
perhaps it's not
in uh increasing the detectability of
fraud uh you know for for lack of a
better State I haven't thought this
through so I'm just kind of speaking
offand but I think that
is uh something to be considered I
um in the industries I work in um I do a
lot of data and Integrity Audits and
I've actually had the pleasure or
displeasure of discovering fraud and
having to then document that and uh
having those companies having to take
actions against people who were
committing fraudulent actions um for
monetary gain and so um it the and the
problem in those cases is is the
detectability literally
takes money mons or years to discover
sometimes and
that's
um a certain number of events have
to accumulate before you can detect a a
sequence of data points that show
something is off we've got an anomaly
here then you have to investigate the
anomaly and then you have to go further
into uncovering what you know Chron you
have to do the forensics to determine
what was done and and then it and only
then you have you begin to tie is there
a motive or an incentive for this person
to have done it to then prove the fraud
it is a very long and cumbersome process
I I know this at least from a data
Integrity standpoint having been
involved in several of those
myself um having said that um I would
imagine that
the AG's office and the Secretary of
State face similar challenges so
um all
right
[Music]
um if it's okay so I think I I've got
I've received good feedback on on this
issue number one things for me to
consider uh uh for these standards for
identification issue number
two
um yes before we move on I just want to
say that one of the um potential
Solutions um even if we're not or we are
whatever if we're going to do the nvy
was it NV National voter Rights Act
if is that and I think I think it was
actually Mr I don't know if it was Mr
Clemen I can't remember who Pro who
first proposed this but the government
holds the uh CI the birth certificates
and evidence
of and we are the government secretary
of state has the ability to
allow the clerks I think think to get so
at least for probably all the males over
18 who were born in New Hampshire we
could just give it to them or make it
available to them or I don't know just
pull it up and see if it's there and
solve that problem so nobody has to run
around and get it and you know
thankfully those people had it at their
home but you know I I know I have mine
but I'm not sure my husband has his at
the house
so I just wonder is there a way that we
as a government and somebody said
yesterday in one of the speeches we are
the
government so could we not make it a
little bit easier for people to get this
um and and get acquisition to it and if
those Federal databases ever become
available then you know we'll be able to
get to those too but is there some way
we could consider that we could help
people get these um and particularly
with maybe neighboring states or others
in the solutions and I don't know if
that's too radical to embrace it this
time but it just seems an easy
solution and then at least reduces the
number of people that have to worry
about
this representative
C and following up on that it would seem
to me that it would also be possible for
the secretary to uh at least for the
women who were born in the state and
married in the state to be able to track
the name change uh due to
marriage uh that's an excellent idea as
well um both of those are excellent
ideas I think if we if we can make um
if we if the state has the wherewithal
to make some of this process easier for
voters to prove their citizenship then
we should Endeavor to do that um it you
there are some
that you know people who have moved from
out of state who may not have that
information there
is I think I read it in
the I forget what where I read it
actually um I think there was some court
order it may have been Arizona versus
the intertribal council or it may have
been one of the other cases um but there
was a series of databases that
secretaries of States could could um
Avail themselves of not Eric sorry um
but um that would allow them access
to uh birth certificates and things like
or at least uh documentation or uh proof
of citizenship so I think there are some
other
aspects um that might be helpful so
representative Newsome you had a comment
yeah um this is of course just pure
speculation but with the current
administration's attempts to get rid of
Birthright
citizenship uh potentially in 18 years
birth certificates won't even the
evidence of citizenship so we may have a
whole another round of issues um just
again that's pure speculation and down
the road and well beyond the scope of
this committee today but just wanted to
point that out as
a
thought yes there are there are many
many countries that do not have
Birthright citizenship so um that is
uh although I never like kicking the can
down the road I I am glad that I won't
have to worry about that aspect I I hope
I hope to be very much uh
retired um by that if Lord willing I'm
still alive
um oh yeah would you like to speak I'm
sorry that's okay please go ahead
represent we and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm here
on behalf of secure democracy and
something that representative Lane just
triggered something in my head um so
secure democracy in West Virginia
instituted a law that allowed their DMV
to share their uh Records with the
Secretary of State's office something
that already exists in New Hampshire on
a limited basis I have language that
would let me back up the DMV when you
get your real ID scans your documents
and keeps them
New Hampshire has a
63% uptake on real ID Which is higher
than the national average so they have
people's birth certificates you know
Social Security numbers whatever they've
done to approve their prove their
citizenship they have that and they know
if it's that document versus a green
card I have language that as soon as I
get back to my computer I can send to
the committee that would allow the
secretary of State's office and the DMV
to share that information and the
Secretary of State's office could add a
column to the voter check list yes
they've proved citizenship or leave it
blank if not it would be very simple
they're already sharing that information
I've spoken to director morasco over at
the DMV he said it is not a problem to
add that information shared to the
Secretary of State's office so if that
is something this committee is willing
to explore I'd be happy to share that
language with you and then it expands it
beyond the onethird of people who were
born in New Hampshire and it would apply
to anyone who has a secret who has a
real ID we've also made the language an
opt in so that way if because we have
the right as uh individuals to delete
information if you want to delete your
photo so that way only the people who
wanted to share their information that
way would would be able to would be able
right um I think the subcommittee would
very much welcome your suggestions um
and if you would uh Endeavor to send
that to us I can do it in the next five
minutes that would be awesome I I think
uh so um if you would send it to the
I'll send it to the five of you y that
would be great um we would very much and
if you could also copy chairman Barry
and he already has a copy of the
language okay all right great
fantastic thank you um thank you very
much
all right um yeah I think clearly when
someone is eligible to be a vo or if we
can do if the state can do whatever is
possible
to assist them in demonstrating that
then I think that's a good thing so we
want to we want to help out our voters
our legitimate voters uh as much as
possible all right uh
any I have asked this before any further
comments on the proof of citizenship
issue all
right all right the second one is the uh
standards for
identification
um clear uh there are right now there
are some uh allowances for other photo
identifications that are not issued by a
government agency either by a state or
federal
agency um and
so there are some questions that have
been raised in some of the bills that
we've are evaluating as to whether or
not
those uh are adequate
and without going into the details
behind why there's some concerns that
about that
um just say that a a New Hampshire
issued ID would indicate both the
domicile qualification being met and as
well as the identity
aspects and the age of course um if you
show up with a New Hampshire driver's
license and a passport or a birth
certificate you you there would be no
issues there um
uh and so I think
just uh there is there are some merits
to having uh government issued
identification
forms and I think one uh possibility is
to take advantage of that sort of
concept and to adapt our rsas to uh to
do that we have at least uh one bill
maybe two I I forget that address this
and I think that would be a good idea
the the the question is um I I I think
that should be something that is
done both at the time of registration
and at the time of obtaining a
ballot uh there are
some uh just in looking at other states
there are
some states where
if a person forgets their identification
they don't have an affidavit but if if
two or more people know them they are
able
to uh sign an affidavit as witnesses
that they know this person and their
that identity established by their
attestation by their Oaths actually um
so that's one alternative method that is
used when someone does not have a
identification for the purposes of
obtaining a
ballot we use
the uh photo aspect in our current law I
believe
and I I'd like to hear from the
subcommittee about any concerns or other
considerations that
uh with regard to using a government
issued
ID representative new um on your um very
thorough four-page handout for the
discussion points you list that the the
quote problem statement is that the
current identification requirements for
qualification permits various forms of
identity of
identification and I challenge that that
is in fact a problem
um that the ENT the identifications that
we allow
today require the photo signature and
other requirements and it's just not a
problem in my
opinion uh thank you for that comment I
think
um
uh yeah perhaps I did not state that
problem State this is the problem of
having long session days and then trying
to do this thing uh trying to prepare
this information late at night in
preparation for a subcommittee meeting
the next day um so sometimes uh the
thought process is perhaps not fully
captured I think I think it's the
subjectivity of reasonable evidence so
let me try and answer some of your
points which I think are are valid based
on the
statement I've made but let me try to
explain that further elaborate on that I
think there is some Sometimes some
subjectivity to what is reasonable
evidence I think there are also some
some concerns
that other types of identification being
used may not have the same standards
that the government uses to establish
identification and
therefore um there are some concerns
about that
aspect um
and and
so
uh I I think and th those are sort of my
my my two points is that some entities
issuing
identifications do not necessarily have
the same government standards or and not
are not under government control and
therefore not under our control and out
of our control
um uh for the purposes of identification
and then
the to some degree the subjectivity of
reasonable evidence um and and we may
need you know do we need to in fact make
that less subjective and more
objective uh perhaps
um
so I think the proposal uh the what I
would propose is that we do require
governmen issued identification
forms uh
I I
do we do need to uh the current rsas do
allow for the photo and things I I still
think we have to have some aspects where
people then subsequently
provide that identification information
so that the Secretary of State doesn't
have to go chasing it down or anything
like that so okay yeah representative
Lane um are are we talking
about to get a ballot or to
register because they're very different
issues right right so right now to
[Music]
to so I I think those are two activities
that both require
identity right so the I
think you know registration requires you
prove four things once you're registered
you only need to require you only need
to prove your
identity so I
don't
um
and
I so I'm I'm fine with that I still
think in in both
situations um I I don't think a person
should ever get a ballot if they can't
be identified i i i and we're not we're
I don't think anybody suggested that I
guess what we've what we've been
thinking about and what we've heard is
not to conflate the requirement for um
for registering for domicile for
approving domicile with the question of
ID and for example when I first moved to
my uh move I moved all of 10 miles
within conquer but I went to a different
Ward so I had to go in and my ID to
identify
myself uh had my old address on it I had
registered with the DMV but I was too
cheap to pay for the
new uh one so they had it in their
records so when I went to hand my ID it
didn't have the same address on it so I
took a utility bill just in case there
was any issue because I'm on this
committee and so um but um but that's an
instance where you know I just pulled
out my driver's license I didn't really
think about it you know
so I think for ID purposes it's a very
different scenario and I think for the
students who have their student IDs on
them all the time particularly if they
don't have a driver's license um so I
mean I didn't have a driver's license
when I was in college because I didn't
have a
car so um it it just means it part of me
is like look at what the purpose is if
we're trying to prove identity to give
somebody a ballot who's already
registered it doesn't have to be
government issued it just has to prove
that they are who they
are and and and I think we had a lot of
testimony on
that and you're you're specifying that
for obtaining a bellot as opposed to
registration exactly so same day
registration that would not be
acceptable
though I didn't say that I was just
addressing one thing at a
time um yes yes indeed
I um so I I think I mean that is that is
the challenge if we can just speak
frankly here is that if a
person is not already
registered
then I I think there are I think there
are some challenges there right um
and I don't think
we're we we're not creating the two
classes of citizens I mean that's
the
um get to you in just a moment Mr BR um
I yeah we're not creating a a you know
two classes of citizens because we're
ostensibly requiring definitive proof of
identity for
registration and and I think I think it
it's incumbent upon New Hampshire to ha
have that kind of
requirement um
and if if in
fact you know someone in in your
situation who you know uh who
who or who has a situation similar to
what you dis discussed is that they
don't have a governmen issued driver's
license
New Hampshire does have a non-driver
identification card that is
obtainable U much as we suggested for
the birth certificates and marriage
certificates within the state we should
look into making that
available um
at at no cost at no cost or nominal very
nominal cost um
to to be a you know to be able to
definitively
do that but I think again I I would
require that for
registration and and it it may be
possible to have uh other forms of
identification but I but I for
registration purposes I think it is
incumbent upon us to
really keep that
threshold
high for the purposes of the state
conducting the election with
Integrity without I don't think that
necessarily
creates
a uh a a burden there are there are many
places where where government IDs would
be
required uh where in your example you
know you could not use a student
ID
um
so Mr O'Brien did you have a comment for
us that's very quick sorry no no that I
we welcome your input this is not a uh
we are we don't claim to be the bearers
of all knowledge um uh so we're we're we
are certainly welcome to have input from
you thank you thank you very much Mr
chair for again for the record Michael
O'Brien with party strategies here on
behalf of America votes um couple things
just want to as we think about ID
specifically to represent Lance point
also under the law right now right so if
I produce a non-government ID I also
have to produce
a government document because I have to
produce my birth certificate or my
passport so and my passport would
obviously cover also identification but
my point is there is like it's not like
you're you're producing something that
the government has has given to you in
order to register to vote um I would
argue that for instance uh UNH is
covered under a government ID because it
is a state institution and therefore uh
is produced by something the state
governs so if we're saying the UNH ID is
okay but the Dartmouth ID is not okay
I don't really know how that works or
why that would be acceptable I also like
darkmouth is a really big employer here
they're a big part of this state as is
bae as is right we have like a lot of
these employers I guess my question to
back up I would just say that you are
always producing something now to
register to vote that is a government
document right and so and I don't
know I mean obviously a mod if I showed
up with my 5-year-old's picture of me
and I said here's that he drew and I
said here's my ID I think the moderator
would say I don't think so uh right also
my my K like love him a five not not
this is I don't think it's his career
path so but you know I I guess all I'm
trying to say here is there is
a um you do have to show some government
documents in order to register to vote
already and also uh that we should trust
our moderators I I think they are being
judicious in what they accept that they
understand that you know the the ID must
be reasonable in order to prove and that
we are showing other government
documents to register um beyond the ID
and yet 46 people were turned away so
because they didn't have an ID but
that's but that's a different or because
they didn't have a one of the proofs one
of the one of the for proofs which is
different than again showing up with
again I show up with an ID from you know
I used to work in the state house right
if I have my state house ID I don't
think I ever had St house was TR I did
for a minute right I showed up to that
would that not have counted even though
it's like I'm a state house employee and
would like there's it just feels like we
and and I would challenge the community
to think about and to ask and I and I am
fairly certain the answer to this is no
has there been a case anywhere where
someone showed a an especially New
Hampshire an ID from bae or from and
they weren't who they said they were
that they had somehow doctored the
picture to change so it matched their
face but provided a name of someone who
who was on the checklist like what are
we at the end of the day what are we
getting at here who do we think we are
what problem do we think we are solving
do we think that people are showing up
with non-governmental IDs and saying I'm
such and such that they and they are
pretending to be a different voter who's
on the checklist are they registering as
a different voter what is the ultimately
what is the problem we're trying to
solve who is this person that we're
trying to stop from doing
something I just it feels very all of it
feels like the any ID from a large
business from a school from a whatever
the case uh is is enough evidence that
you are it's got your picture it's got
your name that is the evidence we are
looking for and then you either have to
produce other documents that match right
with your name and these other things or
you already have done that through the
registration process right I I do I
appreciate those comments I do think the
standards that the DMV exercises are
um and the the identification that they
provide
um may be more than than
uh may may provide more information than
some of the company identifications or
company cards and stuff like that so um
I guess I would say B consistent incon
well but there yeah and and I'm again
I'm not sure
that I would necessarily count uh the
University of New Hampshire system as a
government agency I'm not sure they call
themselves that I don't think they do on
their
websites um and even though there are
people who sit on their boards who
are also are uh government a agents and
uh that sort I'm again I'm not I'm not
quite sure about that uh if we could
classify University of New Hampshire
system as equivalent to the Department
of Motor Vehicles or things like that so
I'm I I'm not sure about that line of
reasoning but that is an interesting
question um all right thank you very
much representative C wishes to speak so
I will yes uh in terms of the proposed
changes I was thinking um two things one
that there may be justification ation
for at least certain circumstances or
all circumstances of
somebody uh getting a non-driver's ID of
not having to pay at all um so you know
whether it's limited circumstances or
all circumstances for for
this uh voting aspect it doesn't matter
what so long as the person can get one
the other one that uh representing Lane
just happened to to talk about was the
change of address without having it on
the on your driver's license I moved
from Kean to conquered and then from
conquered to Laden and in both cases I
did not get the updated license but I
never ran into a problem with it it just
didn't happen to be an issue for me um
but you know representative Lane had it
addressed no I I remember changing
addresses from Nashwood to Hudson and
getting a
sticky you know with the new address on
the back and it was like okay I I I
admire and deeply appreciate the prudent
cost-saving measures implemented by New
Hampshire for such measures
so I I think with that in mind um that
that is something we need to consider
um again I think the the possibility
of easily detected voter fraud because
of an address change for that reason is
is you know
um we we need to find a way we we should
make sure that if there are address
changes that have occurred that we
account for you know some evident you
know you can if if you're not
pre-registered let me think about this
if you're pre-reg I think the laws
already account for just switching you
can notify someone I'm already
pre-registered here I I need to switch
over to here um and so I think that's uh
possible all right any other comments on
the standards for
identification I I guess I'm still not
sure when you say standards for
identification is this just forgetting
Ballot or is this to prove residency
because there in my mind they're two
different
issues I I would say uh thank you again
for that comment I think the
fundamental issue is for registration
okay I because I
think it is incumbent upon New Hampshire
to have qualified voters
so uh who meet the four criteria and
we are able to do that I you
know
um yes representative c i I think that
in in U in answer to representative
Lane's comment there I think we do need
to
identify two different standards of
identification one for registration and
one just to verify that you get a ballot
right yeah
I even if they end up being the same
right no but no that that that is an
excellent point Thank you for stating
that I think that that really is a good
point we need
to um I'm not
sure it's intuitively obvious we have
certainly under
um the registration aspects we have
identification um requirements and I
think we we probably have something
similar but we should make sure within
the rsas that
that those two
activities are understood as
distinct and
sequential and
that um there is perhaps
a very objective standard required for
registration I don't want to say that
there's a lesser one for obtaining a
ballot
but
um if they're collect if they're getting
a ballot in
person
um and they're already
registered we we need you know there
might there might be the the two
standards might be the same they might
be different we need probably need to
kind of think about that over the
weekend make amendments and and present
it uh to the committee on Tuesday but
representative plane I don't want to
beat a dead horse necessarily
but I I come back to the fact that we've
we have no evidence that this is a major
problem are if people are not confident
um I mean there's been a special
commission the governor the secr two
secretaries of State have said we have
safe and secure elections nothing's
perfect but to require everybody to
assume that everybody has easy ability
to get to one just to get to a DMV
station um office and
and it just seems that we are putting St
requiring things that we don't need to
because there's not been a problem why
do we have to eliminate and fix fix a
system that doesn't appear to be broken
we I and I you know again I know how you
all know how I feel so I'll be
quiet thank you for your comments repres
resentative always appreciate
it
please and do the introduction as well
uh Kate Horan I'm actually putting on
another hat I also represent the New
Hampshire Association of counties so
when you are thinking about absentee
voting please remember everyone in your
nursing home votes absentee not everyone
in the nursing home has a photo ID and
they may or may not have all of their
documents they may be with another
family member and right now under the
law a nursing home administrator can
verify someone's ID so please just think
about that because if you require
additional documents that means more
costs and more work for not only the
nursing home but also those in the jail
because if you restrict it just cuz
about 80% to 90% % of the people who are
in your County correctional facilities
are their pre-trial they aren't
convicted so they still have the right
to vote if I happen to live in
Manchester if I run oh yes did you say
80% are pre-trial
yes because we only the counties only
accept people who have been sentenced to
a year or less or are pre-trial so 80 I
think the last time I talked to
Rockingham County out of
140 prisoners 118 were
pre-trial so I'll just give you an
example I happen to live in Manchester
if I commit a crime in exiter I'm going
to be held in Brentwood the
superintendent is not going to allow me
to leave to go get my birth certificate
and my documents to vote nor is the
Manchester Town Clerk going to come to
Brentwood to verify my identification I
will point out County Corrections in
County nursing homes are in a unique
position we know who these folks are
it's not like we're like oh John Smith
is just in bed 18 we know who they are
they're likely on Medicare and Medicaid
they've been verified by the federal
government so please when you guys are
looking at those requirements for
absentees I suggest you pull your county
delegation hat out and put it on and
think about the costs that it will
impact your county
and I see a couple questions that I'm
happy to take yeah I'm just making sure
I get this on my notes um because it is
it I mean those
are that's a good question uh
representative Burnham yes thank you uh
thank you for taking my question um do
you know how many
um uh inmates actually do vote I absente
ballot and I do I'm aware of nursing
home this is the first I've heard about
I don't have numbers but I do know what
the superintendant have told me is if
they still have their voting rights um
then if they ask for an absentee ballot
we facilitate that occurring and
happening now are some people in the
jail for a couple hours are some people
in there for significantly longer I know
Hillsboro County had someone who was in
their pre-trial for over two
years presumably there would have been
an election in there at some point and
if he wanted to vote he still had the
right to
vote okay uh thank you for taking my
question um would you uh distinguish
between the County nursing home and
other nursing homes that are in the
various would not I would suggest that
that would be a problem for all 73
nursing homes in the state there 73 of
them yes and 11 are County nursing homes
Coos has
two
okay and
U oh I just was going to point out that
um in some cases of misdemeanor somebody
may be in there
for um uh prison term convicted but are
still eligible to vote
correct and also um we already have in
the RSA somewhere and I don't remember
which one it is um considering that the
person inside the prison is is
considered away from their Hometown
correct that is an that is an option on
the absentee ballot form
does the subcommittee have any other
questions so um just on the nursing home
so because of the Medicade or medic
Medicaid Medicare um there's a vetting
and identity processing that goes on for
people when you when you apply for
Medicare Medicaid you have to provide
documents Social Security numbers things
like that um
you our concern is right now so a lot of
people who are young adults their
parents may have their birth
certificates rather than themselves that
switches when someone enters a nursing
home often times that the nursing home
will not hold a birth certificate or a
marriage certificate or anything like
that it would be held by the family who
may or may not live in this state
um I don't think the federal
government's going to give out
money unless they're very sure that that
is the
person I I'm just having applied for
Medicare and having gone and having had
to work with Medicaid applications it's
honorous they're very detailed and
they're very thorough
so but no system is perfect
I I would suggest to the committee that
you consider keeping the exemptions for
nursing home administrators to verify
someone's identity because again we know
who's in the nursing home it's not like
it's Joe Smith because obviously County
nursing homes hold the sickest of the
sick and the poorest of the poor they
still have a right to
vote but we know who they are we aren't
holding John Doe in the county nurs
home because if we don't know who they
are we can't get payment for them
right
um they all vot they all vote by
absentee
ballot I think
um I I don't want to say all some you
know there are people in the nursing
home who can come and go as they please
and they can they can go and vote they
may not so the uh Hillsboro nursing home
is in GF toown they may have maintained
their voting rights their domicile in
Amherst where they lived and that is
their their right to do that but they
can switch it to gof toown because that
is where they
live um
could you explain that to me um so if
they were if they were previously
domiciled in and you said Amhurst let's
use that example and they're now as a
resident of Hillsboro County they're now
in the Hillsboro nursing home even
though they no longer have a physical
presence
in
in uh Amherst some families choose to
cond because let's say the person
just physically resides at the Hillsboro
County nursing home but they go and they
spend every single day with their family
in Amherst and they're in the community
in Amherst and they're still very active
in Amherst that's where they want to
vote and they as long as they still have
a physical address there so let's say
it's the family home they can they can
still vote there if they move their
physical address to gtown they need to
vote in gtown I okay that's that's what
in case anybody is listening I just want
to make sure that's clear is that
because doile is defined by physical
presence cor Therefore your explanation
then of someone who uh maybe resides
overnight yes in a gtown nursing
facility um but in fact uh establishes
most of their physical presence correct
in the town of Amherst in this
example meets the doile correct
qualification in that circumstance so
okay thank you that was helpful I
believe representative C has
representative C thank you I have a
follow-up question for you and this is
probably more of an opinion than
anything else uh people who are uh uh
disabled and confined to their home not
a nursing home but just a private
residence uh how would you um think they
should be
handled I think current the current
standard is sufficient because they're
they're not
leaving the ballot is going to their
home why should they need it's
unlikely the likelihood of fraud I think
is very
low and I don't speak for the disabled
Community but I believe that they would
agree with that statement
yeah I think I think it we've heard
other testimony and it's the the issues
with absentee ballot
are uh more along the lines
of confirming the that the
vote was done by the identified voter
and not their neighbor uh or someone
like that and that uh and and parallel
to that is the chain of custody
confirming that in fact
that um vote was done it was sealed in
the proper ballot and
properly uh notorized
as as
needed U by
RSA and that that way we're not treat
someone who votes in person has their
activities observed and you can track a
chain of custody by just witnessing the
person walking to the various uh points
um that is lost with the use of the
absentee ballot and so how do you
compensate that so that you
can treat both ballots
equivalently and and so I think there
there is that aspect and so I think part
of what election law has to wrestle with
is how do we make sure that that
is uh Equitable and the same standard is
is
maintained
um so uh I think that's that's the main
concern that we have I would argue Mr
chair putting back on my secure
democracy hat and taking off my County
hat for a minute sure um that just
because you require someone to provide
IDE as in absentee ballot doesn't mean
someone else didn't fill out that ballot
there's no
proof even if you're sending in
identification with that absentee ballot
that doesn't mean my neighbor still
didn't fill out the
ballot right right and and if if that
did happen we should we should be aware
of that and we should have that we
should properly witnessed and notorized
and so I putting my County hat back on
please realize that notary costs money
fortunately the Secretary of State
um governs the notaries and so there
might be something we can do about that
many states have made it a provision
that uh election
notorized so I think but not a required
service what's that but not a required
service is it do they they require the
notaries to sign those they disallow
charging but they do not
require the notary to take that action
for those ballots it's two two different
issues one is charging for it one is
doing the
action the notary still has the option
not to do the opt not to do that action
when they're not getting paid for
it okay I'm not
uh I'm trying to remember of what I've
read if that's true in all states I'm
not sure that
is uh due to anti-slavery Provisions in
the Constitution I doubt a state can
force somebody to take an action and
work for no
payment perhaps for you can't for you
can't for you can't force pro bono I'm
sure that there are many people who are
notaries
do it for free but I do not think we
cance them to do it for free and we can
also authorize other people besides
notaries to do it such as these people
in the nursing homes um and um and and
like we authorize the town clerks
because they're not a lot of the Town
clerks are not officials yeah election
officials are not official notaries so
so we could authorize other people so
that they don't have to be truly
notaries and get that little official
stamp I think that's what I'm trying to
suggest is that if you're going to
require a notary that please include the
county superintendent and the County
Nursing Home administrators as
authorized approvers because they know
who these people
are because the town clerk is not going
to drive over in my example where I get
arrested in exiter and I'm held in
brenwood the Manchester Town Clerk does
not have time to come over and verify my
identity the correction superintendent
should be able to say yes she is who she
says she
is agreed I I
think right uh representative C I was
just thinking we were just dealing with
a bill for providing vouchers for uh
people to get their uh um birth
certificates and things like that maybe
that could also
include uh
getting a notary to witness somebody who
cannot
travel yes I I think um again I'm trying
to I do believe that there are some
states that maybe they have a nominal
fee
um and I I think it was in Crawford
versus Maran where they did not consider
that to be an onerous burden on the
voter but uh nor did it um in case
anyone was wondering nor did it cross
the threshold of a pull
tax
um so all right there
so I I
do appreciate the aspect that there are
specific individuals that could be
deemed for absentee ballots in these
particular situations election officials
who would have the responsibility and
authority to be able to authenticate a
person um and without requiring a notary
I think um I think a notary might
be appropriate for those who are in
other situations traveling you know out
of state on business for example
something like that um where again that
that burden doesn't seem to be
inappropriate to the privilege of
voting all
right um thank you thank you Mr
organ all right I think we've uh tackled
the two uh two issues
um any further comments on issue two
that aren't that haven't already been
said de yes not only it's been dead it's
yeah yeah the horse does not complain
enough that's right um all right so
let's move to issue three the
non-resident voters
so again uh in my and this as
representative Newsome has already
pointed out my problem statements may
not always be perfectly worded but I
will endeavor to um
um to lay out the problem so we have
persons who use outof state
identification but they have a
legitimate New Hampshire
domicile um and but once they either
register or vote um and we heard testony
from the Secretary of State about this
they are obligated to fulfill the
resident requirements and and there have
been advisory opinions from the Supreme
Court about that as well as um the 2020
case of Casey versus New Hampshire
Secretary of State there
were uh five questions asked of the
Supreme Court they declined to answer
the third one but they did answer the
other five and uh or the other four of
those five and one of them certainly uh
one if not more of them alluded to the
fact that yes once someone votes and
exercises that
domicile um for voting purposes then
they are obligated to fulfill the
resident
obligations
um however we we do know from testimony
that this that we heard in the Full
House on House Bill 133 is
that um for those people who did use
outof State
identifications um there's only been an
80 or a 20 to 25% something around those
numbers don't hold me to exact numbers
please but only a very very minor
percentage of those
voters who have used an outof state
identification have Then followed
through on those residency requirements
and that is a problem that is a
non-compliance
so um you know what's the the problem is
that our voting list potentially have
people who have not fulfilled their
resident obligations
and if certainly if someone does this
repeatedly this this is a a willful
disregard of the residency requirements
and I think something that could in fact
constitute voter fraud you you're always
looking for voter fraud there you go I
I've laid out a possible case for one
one possible case yes um which I would
May argue but we'll get to that later so
and and we do know we do know in the
last election that there were
4,812 outof state driver's licenses used
and so um again I think that's I'm sorry
what was that number again
4,812 I believe that is correct um about
approximately
approximately and
um
so you know if we
have only 20% of that
complying that would
be uh now I'm required to do high level
math here about a thousand yeah so about
a thousand so that
would if these people failed to continue
to act and continued to vote there there
you would have and had a requirement to
get a license and had a requirement to
get a
license or had already had a
license um
then uh such persons would
be um potentially again I get a series
of circumstances that have to they all
have to come together it has to be a
perfect storm of
concurrences um and I I'm redundant
there sorry uh they even so at those
point I think we would have a
legitimate uh case of voter fraud or you
maybe may be inadvertent and unaware but
uh uh ignorance is not uh excuse I
suppose all right so what is the
proposed solution at least from my
perspective well I think first it it's
incumbent upon us to increase awareness
of the residency requirements and
implications
and um I think it's also important that
we identify residency requirements on
the voter registration forms that that
people sign but without making the forms
unnecessarily complex I think the you
know the court case for
sb3 I believe had uh comments along
those lines that that sp3 had created
complex registration forms and therefore
made
it uh difficult for voters to understand
what they were signing I think
um you know we we simply need
to
um provide simple statements about uh
your your active uh registration and
voting uh requires that you fulfill New
Hampshire state residency requirements
which may
[Music]
include uh transferring a current
driver's license to New
Hampshire and other similar activities
something along those
lines
um I think one of the things that we
could
do uh in the and make it more clear in
the RSA about these sorts of
implications um is to Define some of
these uh aspects in under eligibility
and
then um uh specified in the voter
qualifications and registration forms in
those sections of the RSA as well again
without making them unnecessarily
complex so as to make registration a
burden but um so I would I would propose
something U maybe under eligibility to
add something to the effect of the
active registration or voting requires
the register or voter to comply with the
residency requirements for New Hampshire
compliance with New Hampshire residency
requirements is considered a verifiable
Act of intent to make the place
designated by the registrant to doile is
claimed and then failure to comply with
the residency of requirements of New
Hampshire law invalidates any claim to
establish a physical place of presence
with an intent to make that place a
domicile and re renders the registrant
as unqualified for the purposes of
voting in future elections until as such
time the residents requirements are met
continued failure to comply with the
residency requirements of New Hampshire
law is considered a willful violation of
the election laws of the
state again I think again I've tried to
laid out a series of circumstances where
one is you know for whatever reason they
haven't complied but compliance is not
necessarily fraud and we had that
discussion earlier today and I'm I'm not
looking
to cast dispersions on someone who has
not been compliant as if they were
committing fraud I'm simply trying to
distinguish between those two levels but
someone who continues to violate this is
really at that
point not just merely not complying but
actually in you know committing voter
fraud at that point and so I think we
need to be clear about this under the
eligibility aspects and then uh make the
proper uh changes to the voter
qualification registration form sections
of the RSA in order to address that um
and so I would propose uh for example
I'll I'll try and provide some
amendments to uh my bill 289 to remove
the aspects that we discussed earlier
today but then to add these sorts of
residency requirements under eligibility
again not again
explaining you know dool is what is
needed to qualify but
that that act of voting or registration
then kicks in residency requirements
because I think that's
fair representative Lane I I guess I
don't agree with you um I'll
respectfully disagree I do not think
that the fact that you um if you satisfy
and register and you show domicile and
done everything the fact that you choose
not to get a New Hampshire driver's
license or that you choose to not get uh
the non driver identification should not
it's not should not make take away your
right to vote which is the most
important right you have if you make
those choices it in no way is saying
that you're committing fraud all you're
doing is not complying with other laws
of New Hampshire and if if they want to
share that list with DMV and DMV wants
to go after those people for the for a
violation of that law go at it but you
don't take away people's right to vote
simply because they don't go out to DMV
and get a driver's license or what other
residency requirements are I don't even
know because one of my questions was
what are the other residency
requirements and I'm not trying to be
funny I I just honestly don't know if
there are other ones that were that I'm
not aware of um and you know like
registering your car maybe a lot of
people don't have the
money to register their car and so they
are forced to take the chance um that
they're not going to get caught and and
I guess you know we all learn from our
own experience but you know I worked in
legal aid for nine years I mean my
clients they they can't I mean trying to
come up with 50 extra dollars at the end
of the week was a huge burden taking
time off to go to the clerk's office or
to go to DMV and stand in line for two
hours is just something they can't do
they're most of them are taking care of
somebody or they're me they have mental
health issues I mean there's a myriad of
circumstances that you know fortunately
most of us don't have but a lot of
people in this state do and it's been
consistent stantly I can't remember who
did this survey but most people in the
United States and I don't know I can't
remember the percentage but it's a
really high percentage of people who
don't have 400 who a $400 expense
unexpected they can't cover it so which
is why I get so worked up about the
passport and all these extra cost
because a lot of people in our state do
not have those and but that doesn't mean
they shouldn't be able to vote and so
the more barriers and the more
requirements we put up the more people
we are not allowing to
vote
and I I just don't I think we have to
think very carefully before we start
saying oh because you didn't get a
driver's license or you didn't register
your car you are not g to you were not
going to be allowed to vote I'm not sure
that would stand up in court but you
know I'm not a lawyer anymore so I I
mean I don't know but I just think we
have to think about those things before
we go off and say oh let's do
legislation about this so and one of the
things I was thinking about with a lot
of these bills is should we retain
them and because I mean realistically we
have what two weeks a week five days not
much time to to improve these bills in
light of all that we've heard so do we
select a few to retain and work on them
and get them at least to the point where
you're not having to listen to me say
this over and over
again so thank
you yes representative C uh we we do
need to consider the possibility of
people not having any photo ID at all
and it's not actually a requirement for
living to have an
ID uh if they don't drive if they don't
own a car car if they don't need to go
buy a beer you know they just don't need
an
ID and that's they can legally live
their life that
way yes
we again I we we run up against that
kind of non-driver identification
aspect um
representative
vernham I just had a comment to make
because I mean with all these
identification Social Security and all
of that I when uh my children were still
young and my oldest was about to get a
job a summer job I realized I could not
find their social security cards in the
midst of my whatever I don't know what
happened because those are issued based
upon the birth certificate right that
all kind happens at the same time and
then you don't use them unless you have
insurance that you need to write down
their social security number and that's
about it that I know could recall uh
maybe if you sent them to school I'm not
sure but because I homeschooled but um
however so when I when I lost in my
house there's social security guards and
I knew I had to get this cuz in a few
months she was going to start a job and
she would need that so I took my
children to the Social Security office
which just getting inside was a
complete circus with my children so um
the problem that I came to is that I
couldn't prove they were my
children I had their birth certificate
with my name on it and their name on it
but I did not have a photo
ID which was kind of interesting because
I thought well I mean I homeschool told
them I didn't need a photo ID or a
school ID for them so
um I can see why this is like an issue
you know proof of verification but this
was a this was and this I had to go back
a couple times they were not willing to
just give them a copy of their social
security card so um but I think that
it's important why I say this it's it's
I think that we need to make sure that
we're verifying people who are are who
they say they are when they're voting
it's just as important what that answer
is what that what the final solution is
I'm not sure because we kind of just run
around and beat every possible uh idea
but um it is it is very difficult to
prove someone's
identity even if they were to create one
themselves CU then that's not really
government or legitimate however I think
could it be possible that and I know
this might be I'm just throwing it out
there but wherever they are and I'm not
I'm excluding the county issue but
wherever the people are residing is that
something where they can maybe have some
type of identity from the clerk's office
I mean we get their we're registering
there we pay for our dog licensing which
is coming up and all this stuff like is
this another possibility that you know
if we are visiting there and you know
most people have driver's license most
people have ident this would be a rare
few but did did this did this topic come
up about possibly having some type of
verification through the clerk's office
I thought I heard it somewhere I can't
really recall but is this do you think
this could be a
possibility I think it was Mr uh Clement
totz who brought it up in his testimony
at one point I don't remember which Bill
he was testifying on but I think that's
where I kind of got the idea when he
mentioned something like that but I
don't know for
sure I I know I heard it so thank you I
wasn't sure but and and the thing is
like birth certificates you can get real
easy now because it's all been logged in
so that pretty much right like it's on a
database are exceptions yeah okay
there's always exceptions not everybody
lives the same I get it but I mean that
is a available um you know so if there
are those documents available in the and
we can have something available at the
clerk's office to verify I don't know if
that's another option to
consider representative new um according
to my notes that was on house built 618
when we heard that idea and I don't know
who it was from but it was 618 I have in
my not it might have been you bring it
it might have been you bringing it up at
the time too but it was worthy enough
that I wrote a note about it so so I I
think uh and I'm doing this from memory
but if I if I'm not mistaken in some of
the court cases that we heard about um
there was some discussion that at one
point there were some states that
limited or or that you know historically
limited their Wards to 250 people so
someone could ostensibly know everyone
there uh those days perhaps are gone um
but I think um even so I think you know
that's an interesting aspect of if we're
wanting someone to be identified at a
ward then what can we do to facilitate
the identification at that Ward through
the town clerk that or the clerk's
office there that that is an interesting
aspect um
so all
right represent new some followup there
thank you on um slightly different well
for on the sheet um believe it or not
I'm actually G to have something good to
say about
it on uh under proposed solution you
have the increased awareness of Resident
requirements and
implications um I think that's a great
idea and I don't know if it would be as
simple as a handout that the ballot
clerks could give somebody when they do
use that out of state ID that's a great
idea uh something like that would be
great um and then getting back to
representative Lane's comments about how
a DMV
violation shouldn't rise
to the where where the penalty should
not be to remove your right to vote I
guess another way that I was kind of
thinking that through and an analogy
would be that you get a speeding ticket
right and you're no longer allowed to
possess a firearm
interesting that it's a DMV violation
and a constitutional right being taken
away and I like that analogy actually I
I doubt anyone would feel confident and
comfortable with a speeding ticket
taking away your right to gun ownership
right I know I wouldn't want my guns
taken away over a speeding ticket so yes
um
yes I I do
appreciate that how do we deal with this
issue of ongoing
non-compliance that's the challenge and
I think that's the the DMV and I don't
know if there are ways to communicate
that back and forth through local level
reports up to the Secretary State who
then talks to
DMV um and again the other problem is
that as the testimony we heard is
that just because you don't get the New
Hampshire driver's license doesn't mean
mean you're not in
compliance that we that there are
certain circumstances of not driving in
the state not owning a car in the state
where you can be residents domiciled
whatever words they all are um that may
that may or may not be the same um even
with all that you still don't need to
have a New Hampshire driver's license
and I think as representative C said you
don't need an ID to live your life so
again not getting
one it is not Prima evidence of
violations so it it is a challenge and I
just don't
know what the answer is and I certainly
don't think we can come up with an
answer in the next week uh to to make a
uh a bill amendment to to solve that
this this term
does uh thank you for that comment does
H yeah
so it's funny we've by law we've
combined the concepts of domicile and
Resident but then we need to continually
separate them in for enforcement
purposes
oddly enough because as you said
it the doile can be
maintained and someone
[Music]
can again
I'm the doile could be
maintained for voting purposes they
still have their physical presence but
their failure to comply with resident
requirements at that point is has to be
sort of distinguished from the
constitutional right to
vote yeah the the way I think about it
is what is the definition for voter
registration or voter residency as
opposed to other types so DMV residency
UNH residency so that that term can be
used in a lot of different context and
doesn't always mean the same thing and I
think it's we T I know I tend to want to
put lump things like resident means
resident and every single the same thing
in every single situation but that's
really not what we have and I think
that's why they finally gave up and said
Domino domicile and residents with
respect to voting are the same but but
it's not the same when you look at DMV
or un UNH you know whether you're going
to get to pay instate tuition or not and
there's probably other requ other ones
out there I just don't know um but
it's we shouldn't fall into the Trap of
trying to say that the word resonant
mean or residency or whichever one we're
using means the same thing in every
context and that's and I think
that's part of the education process for
everybody um and I think handing out
that thing might be a good idea and to
educate people and it could also be that
um the SOS and
DMV um can work together to to do
something like that I don't know if they
have a link or not I I can't figure that
out I think they do I think that I think
also that house bill 133 was meant to
address some of these aspects so
um all right all right so I think um but
those are valid points The
Residency has multiple
definitions
um or or or you that's not the right way
to say it maybe is you can you can have
multiple
residences um but for voting purposes
you can't have multiple
domiciles um
it's it's confusing so
yes representative
SE I know we have a a u provision in the
RSA stating that uh voting uh doile for
voting purposes but that always sort of
annoyed me because as I see it you can
only have one domicile for all your
purposes and you can change it whenever
you need to but at any one given time
you can only have one and that but
that's just my feeling I don't know
whether there's any legal basis for that
so so it's it's very interesting if you
read
through like for instance tax
law you can have someone who has a
temporary absence from an address for
education
purposes um and you can have I think
there's a reference where you can have a
do I think this is in the rsas as well
you can have a domicile for voting
purposes and also have a temporary
absence from that
domicile um that's
yeah
Services yeah arm Services yeah armed
services usually the one that most
people ring up are people who go do
residencies doctors who go do
residencies and it's the other example
they always come up with I can't
remember but you know in in I I
mean yeah I think it's
uh and and because the state each
state implements these things
independently with just having to align
as as required with Federal requirements
if they're applicable or
not
um again it's it's it's
very confusing uh for that reason
because you you I think
you I don't think other states are
wrestling with they don't use the word
dool let me put it that way there there
are other states that don't use the word
domicile
so um and and maybe that's part of it we
need to think about how we how we uh
change that I think that's what really
is behind the suggestion by Mr Richard
for moving toward a New Hampshire
citizen
voter all right any are there any other
comments on the non-resident voter
issue they haven't been said before that
this hasn't been said before I'm not
sure that the term non-resident voters
is very is good because if you're not a
resident you shouldn't be voting so it
kind of implies
so I would just
say I don't know I don't know what title
I would come up with but when I first
read it I went how can we have
non-resident voters if they're a
non-resident voter then they're
committing fraud well I you know how how
can we have voters who use who are
voting in New Hampshire who use out of
state
identification because they're just
proving who they are they're not proving
that they live they can prove how that
they live in New Hampshire in other ways
the ID is just to show who they are
possibly representative C possibly the
title could be uh voters with
non-resident
identifications yes
I uh I inherited that title uh because
that was the subcommittee's title given
to me just so you know so so just um I
do try and be very careful in my wording
but sometimes I inherit things that
are well we are trying to make sure that
the non-resident voters don't vote in
our state
exactly um all
right while allowing the residents to
vote in the state
yes yes absolutely all right
we've uh talked about those three
things
um let's uh the the fourth one is
absentee ballots all right
so I I think again this is just my my
perception thinking about this late at
night but trying to take into
account all the testimony we've heard
the court cases I've
reviewed uh the research that we've been
presented currently and and we and we
did hear the Secretary of
State testify that he felt that that
there were some aspects of the absentee
ballot process I won't
say you registration and obtaining a
ballot but that may
be um
and and we heard Mr Richard's testimony
about the affidavit aspects of that that
could be tightened up so I think um I
think the problem I see is that absentee
ballots May currently be obtained by
non-registered voters so they can
request a ballot even if they haven't
registered yet I believe that's correct
and then they have to prove they have to
provide that proof of
they have to provide the qualifications
again I have to uh confirm that but I
think that's possible I thought there
was a process to register
absentee which is separate and distinct
from requesting the absentee ballot and
this is again one of the and I found the
same issue when I was going through this
stuff is conflating the different steps
in the process between registration
requesting the ballot and then returning
the ballot yes as
different things and it and it it is
hard to keep track of yeah well I I I I
mean uh I don't want to suggest
something wildly crazy but I think it
might be it might be helpful at some
point to even think you know much as you
did with the finance aspects last year
is to just think about a overhaul where
we would distinguish yeah I know sorry
where we would distinguish those two
activities more clearly than the rsa's
do now now um because I do think there
is confusion about
that um and
I
um all right
so all right with all right so without
an election official sign off you know a
clerk signing an envelope for a voter
submitting an in for example a clerk
signing it like I I've done this at my
own in my own town i' I've know I was
going to be away on business travel I
went in the week prior obtained an
absentee ballot filled it out there
signed all the necessary forms and
handed it directly to the clerk so you
know there was full chain of custody
full identification I had already
registered so no issues there
um but as we heard from Mr Richard's
testimony uh there are some absentee
ballots that don't have a formal
confirmation of the voting by the
identified voter there's a self
attestation I think is how he
characterized it um but there's not a a
thirdparty
such as a election official public
notary
other uh individuals who might be you
know we certainly heard from Miss Horan
um you know uh County Corrections
administrators uh nursing home admin
ministrators who might be able to do
something in in those
situations uh you know could
authenticate that that voter made you
know again for someone who was disabled
uh because we we do want to take into
account that situation if that they
could indicate their vote to a third
party who then completed the vote the
ballot on their behalf and then again
had all of that documented so that you
know were sufficiently documented so
that it it was shown very
clearly
um that the circumstances of of that
vote uh has uh in authenticity and
integrity and and it's documented and
the moderator when they receive that
absentee ballot and then have to count
those votes can verify that as
appropriate all right um
so
I uh so again the two aspects are simply
that there's not a formal confirmation
of the voting by the identified voter
and there's a loss of any chain of
custody confirming the Integrity of the
absentee
ballot um what's the adverse impact is
that the Integrity of some ABS ballot is
suspect uh when there's a lack of the
confirmation or or an insufficient chain
of custody
um you know some possibilities things
would be absentee B ballot absentee
voters must pre-register in person now
again I think we would have to take into
account the uh Corrections facilities
nursing homes things like
that uh if the absentee voter fails to
provide the documents necessary for
registration um you know what would we
do would we treat them like a u aava
voter
uh quite possibly because at that point
there's no other choice we don't want to
deny them the opportunity to vote but
simply you know we don't
have all the documentation necessary so
I do think um especially after Mr
Richard's testimony I do think we need
to uh explore creating a a voter
authentication affidavit envelope um
something that election official or a
public notary or you know a uh
Corrections Facility administrator or
nursing home facility administrator
could
sign
and you know uh thereby
identify um you know uh what the that
the voting has occurred
properly so I think those
are I think the two
uh um things is you know you we modify
the envelope and I apologize my computer
uh key for e is C giving me problems and
I see all the typos here and I apologize
for that but it's like uh again some of
them envelop is a word but it it it was
meant to be envelope so um if you see
under proposed changes so it was not
caught by spell check unfortunately
spell check yeah and the is still a word
um from uh the old English
language
so uh again things not caught during
spell
check so I think uh those are the two
things that I see as as helping to
improve the absentee ballot
situation um there are changes that
would have to be made in a number of
cases I think there's um good support in
in some of the other cases referenced
again it was starting to get uh very
very late at that point and so um so I
additional considerations is to limit uh
the deadline for receiving absentee
ballot request by mail simply because
there's not time to return it at that
point um and require a completed
registration prior to dispensing with an
absentee ballot if again um I may need I
probably do need to double check that
again I may have conflated registration
with obtaining a ballot but uh for for
the absentee ballot aspect so I think
those are some potential Solutions along
those lines um thoughts and
comments representative Burnham yes I do
have a comment this actually occurred
Tuesday and I I hope that I'm speaking
on this in the proper
way that I saw it was um I was helping
with the absentee ballots as far as
getting them prepared and um one
individual
um had requested an absentee ballot the
Monday prior which is fine however was
not a registered voter so then had to
come in Tuesday to
register and then provider absentee
ballot so I kind of thought it was a
little strange
I mean obviously this may not happen
very often but is that proper procedure
if she came in to register but still
submitted the absentee
ballot I would think that when they show
up in person they should be tossing
their absentee and getting a Same Day
quote unquote regular is what I would
think
but I as school moderator I don't deal
with elections the way that the town
moderator does I'm still the election
official and do the counting but that
kind of call would be the town
moderator's call at least in my town um
but that's an interesting scenario
thanks for sharing that yeah and he did
call it he he checked on and verified
yep she registered and they accepted the
absentee ballot but I just thought it
was I felt the same way if you could
come to register why not just vote but
that was just kind of one of those
really strange things that happened with
but in theory it's the same questions
the same ovals
so
yes it's kind of a no difference in the
end that the ovals are still getting
counted the same way but it is it is an
odd situation and I think less important
in a town where the ballots are the
same but other and if some of the other
balloting pre certific pre certificate
questions come into play that could have
different answers and could be I I would
almost uh suggest your moderator reach
out to the municipal Association and add
that to the training seminar uh because
that is an interesting one that I bet
happens elsewhere
too yeah I think there there are some
questions about whether you would treat
that as the absentee ballot as a spoiled
ballot at that point and
then um and then you void that and
then request the person to vote in
person
um again plans change so it's you know
if someone thought they would be away
and filled it out with they weren
registered so yeah so right so there's a
lot of how did they get a ballot without
registering see so that's that's what
I'm concerned about someone got an
absentee ballot and they weren't I did
ask the clerk that I said to them why
did you give a ballot if they weren't
registered I I don't I might be missing
something but that's just the scenario
that was presented one no I'm just
kidding no that is a very serious
problem and I don't mean to diminish
that at all but I mean obviously that
would have been checked by the
supervisor checklist that morning who
goes through to verify the absentee
ballots but I just thought why would
that be even entertained from the
beginning right it possibly a similar
name with somebody already on the
registry I the the mean I'm not going to
speculate on that right the mechanism
should be no ballots unless registered
so um representative C I know you have
uh some ideas here that you want to
share with us well first I wanted to
follow up on on the conversation we were
just having here please do is uh my
understanding of the reason
for uh having the absentee ballots
processed after like 11:00 a.m. or some
particular time is so that a person who
thought there were going to be away
mailed in an absentee ballot but then is
able to come in can come in before the
absentee ballots are started and they
can mark them as being voting in person
instead of
absentee that's my understanding
too isn't it possible though that you
can
still and I'm I've been reading all
these new statutes so I'm a little the
existing statute can you not because I
know we heard testimony from a couple
the clerks that they send them to people
by email I mean that that they're
requested by email so it could be that
under the existing law that they ask for
the full package registration and
everything and then I I don't know it
just I I can't remember what the I I'm
embarrassed to say I can remember I it
is it is complicated it gets conflated
and I think we need
to um
review that and make sure that we
uh uh separate those two those two
activities for absentee ballots more
clearly so that I
I I do think
that that fraud could occur I I want to
be careful in my phrasings for the uh
esteemed representatives to my left I
want I want to so it is important
that
the B an absentee ballot never be sent
out to someone who is not
registered because that has a potential
for
fraud and uh
so uh you know and that that
theoretically could happen again for
very uh ostensibly good purposes but um
that is a way that fraud could be
introduced and
therefore um more easily introduced and
therefore we should do things to
mitigate the potential of it occurring
and so with that in mind I think it's
it's important that we we do clarify
that now
um representative C has some uh some
ideas here for to share with us I
understand representative Burnham has to
leave thank you very much um if you have
any further suggestions um or uh
possible
amendments um to this
please um let us know and we will be I
don't know if you caught this early on
we will be
meeting
um uh Tuesday morning at
9 um the the only problem I see is we um
we may not be meeting here so we'll
we'll figure out where we're meeting um
who knows the closet over here yeah yeah
quite possibly but um and then um I I
will see if I can get a more
Fuller report out uh this
weekend um or on Monday and we'll try
and review it um you know if I am able
to do this by
uh you know sometime over the weekend I
I really encourage people to get
comments back to me you know offline so
that we can review as complete a pack uh
as complete a report as we possibly can
on our Tuesday meeting uh with
recommendations for the uh committee can
I just make another comment please I
just want to thank you for putting that
report together it kind of really helped
narrow the issues and put them in order
so it's uh for the no I it's tough
there's it's sometimes things web
together and I'm I'm very thankful that
you did that so thank you for giving
that information like that I I hope I I
thank you representative Burnham I do
hope that the subcommittee finds it
useful I've tried to
really
uh analyze and synthesize the issues
into as concise a document as possible
and um while I may have failed with some
of my problem statements and
solutions um um it's always easier to
edit than it is to do the initial draft
but and so I do thank you I it it gave
us a good place to start kind of coaling
thank you I I I do appreciate that I do
think these are the I think the four
issues that we're wrestling with uh by
and large there may be other nuances but
um anyway I want I do want to again
representative bam thank you um
representative C you have some thoughts
on the chain of custody for absentee
ballots would you please uh discuss that
or introduce that to us and discuss it
please okay um this is uh not as it's in
current rsas this is what I was trying
to um piece together and then putting in
what I thought was the use of a
notary um and you can see where it's in
there but
basically when the um clerk mails out a
uh absentee ballot
package at that point it's it's in the
post office or whatever Delivery Agent
is in is using it um there's no real
chain of custody on that uh when the
voter receives the ballot package if
they then then go to a notary
public then you can say that the chain
of custody
resumes uh because when the uh voter is
with the notary public the notary public
can uh verify the person's
identification and that the ballot is
blank they haven't they aren't haven't
been given a previously marked Ballot or
anything like that and also the I would
think the um notor should at least
attempt to uh confirm that the ballot is
the correct ballot for that person they
obviously aren't going to be able to
prove it but you know if I asked for one
does it say the town of Lowden does it
say the know
um uh the uh March 11th
uh uh Town election or whatever it is uh
but
and then while the voter is there but
not where the um notary can see them
actually Mark the ballot they should
Mark the ballot refold it put it in the
inner
envelope and then the uh notary can then
verify all the uh information on the
affidavit and put the notary seal on it
and that um provides a u a chain of
custody with a notary seal because when
it gets back to the town and to the U
moderator when he or she is ready to
process the ballot they can check to see
that the envelope is still sealed the
notary uh certificate is all filled out
and they know that the um person has
been
identified and that there is a uh ballot
inside the envelope
um so that's that's the chain I was
looking at and I noted up there uh the
notary public or other recognized legal
Witnesses and I jotted down some
possible legal Witnesses
below uh obviously we just talked about
nursing home administrators U um also uh
long-term for somebody who's a long-term
hospitalization some Hospital uh
administrator we haven't uh um
identified how to handle uh people who
are
homebound but so that list can be added
to and probably needs to be codified to
be uh
legitimate but that was just my thoughts
on trying to keep track of the um chain
of custody on on the ballots the all the
regular ballots there is the chain of
custody process already uh prescribed in
rsas whether it's what we think it ought
to be or not
that's you know it may they may need
adjustment too but I didn't try to
adjust uh uh address that in this
particular
statement thank you representative see I
think that's very helpful um I think
this is a good list
of uh I think this is a good process as
you've outlined and I think the
identification of a of a starting group
of legal Witnesses is very helpful as
well
um and
I yes I think I oh yeah I put for
somebody out of the country um I don't
know whether uh embassies or um other um
um state secret U uh State Department
functions um have notary publics or what
they call them or whether it be the
charge head to Affairs or the Ambassador
himself or yeah who knows I know they
have a they don't call them notaries but
I
know that there there is a term and I
can't
remember right yeah and maybe that's
wording we could use someone who
someone who is
uh capable of administering an oath
might be another is another term that we
could use to capture people that that
can serve as witnesses to the yeah
because I don't think we want to list
limit it to State Department staff right
um because I know like where my kids
went to school in Scotland the nearest
consulate was over three hours away
right so that could be
problematic from an access point but I'm
sure that they would have some other
person to administer
Oaths is that something think we can ask
our crack legal
researcher to find out so if you want to
phrase the question representative lane
or
representative I think we we want to
know what how to express the fact that
the equivalent of a a notary or an
official witness is in another country
and I don't if it's uh somebody in the
state Department maybe want to maybe
include them but are there other terms
that we should be looking at rather than
just a charge a affair or um amb you
certainly don't want to have to be be
the ambassador but you know I mean
something along does that make am I
yes you said it much better than I did
thank you yeah so um I will send a
request to Chairman Barry and and he
will forward it to you I'll I'll copy
you on the original request but
um uh it will be directed to Chairman
Barry and he'll approve
it
um and I again I think even if it's um
completed after the uh subcommittee
report is done I think it still can be
included as evidence and and that would
be
helpful um because I
think we we do want to try and uh take
into account as as much of this as
possible
um all
right well thank you very much
representative
c a quick question um with the notary
seal a lot of those but not all are
raised and would that on it the ballot
itself because if it's going through the
envelope and everything it's going to
catch top and bottom and hit the
intermediate ballot is that that would
that create problems for the voting
machines um perhaps we
could
um have a statement if if embossing if
notarizing the
envelope uses an emboss seal that the
embossing should be
done um on the flat or prior to on the
flap prior to ceiling or something like
that prior to including the envelope so
as not to damage
prior to including the ballot so it's
not too we can we can work on that down
the road something like that but yeah I
think
that's we should we should include some
provision for that probably my initial
thought on that was maybe to have the
envelope have a large
flap a fullsize flap that could be uh
notary seal on and then and then the gum
seal on it
yeah good as long as it's considered
yeah thank you I appreciate your
thoughts on that and and sort of having
this list is very helpful in kind of
seeing the process and I I like it a lot
because it doesn't and I know this was a
concern of yours during uh committee
testimonies not to have
duplicative identification process
through the process um and I I greatly
appreciate your work on that
thanks all
right I think um
just this discussion points
paper I I think the only thing is that
needs I think I I need to do some
serious work on page one based upon the
testimony from representative Lynn who
uh as everyone should know was a former
New Hampshire Supreme Court justice so
and chief justice and chief justice so
um he does not come uh he is certainly
much more qualified to talk about legal
aspects than than uh
myself and so I really respect his
opinion and was very glad that he could
stop by this
morning
um
so
um what I I'd like to do is put together
a um a more Fuller narrative
supporting these discussion points as
well I think I can do that over the
weekend I I hope um and then uh give
that to you know revise this based upon
comments and then uh give that to
everyone for review and then hopefully I
would say late Sunday night that would
give the subcommittee Monday to review
and then I could make any revision
and then we could discuss the completed
report Tuesday morning so you think the
report going to be something do you let
me let me ask you if I had a narrative
sort of and then this was one of the
attachments you know we I would talk
about these at a high
level and then include something like
this as an attachment that would discuss
it yeah
wasn't sure yeah okay I'm not sure
either quite frankly but I um you're in
charge but I well I'm I do you
I I'm an engineer and I find that kind
of breaking this down helps me to
understand it not that I get every point
right but um but then it's easier for
people to point out where I'm wrong
actually because you know it's been
identified so I think from
uh that aspect I you
uh I I I do think it helps uh to some
degree and
then so that's the report aspect and
then do we go back and and say give them
a um a recommendation for each of the
bills that we have or you know like you
know
I I'm fairly certain that most of the
Republicans will not be voting for my
bill that that is quite possible 385 I I
bet a lot of money on that one uh but I
do have an amendment and I do have you
know something so I don't know if
there's other amendments to these that
we're going to expect and they want we
want to fix or do we want to ask people
to retain them or um has that's a I'm
just saying it's a lot of work to get
done
right but if somebody if you if you want
to tackle that unfortunately I think
you're on three different bills you have
one or two yeah I only one um yeah but
it's the longest one
um do you uh so I I will I'll reach out
to representative Burnham but I would
say if if you have recommendations for
any of the
bills or Andor amendments you would like
like to make if you could make those to
me by you know Noonday
Sunday and then what I will do is I will
consolidate all the input
and
uh go from
there and and you know try in include
that in the report as much as possible
um
I
just okay so
um I I do think it will help us because
if if there are some um I'll use the
term euphemistically bad bills we could
be able to identify them and and as
possible amend them prior to
Tuesday
um and likewise if there are some that
are bad bills that cannot be amended we
can
uh propose an itl out of the
subcommittee for you know the full
committee or if there is something that
we think yes this has possibilities but
we need more time to work on it
um you know and I I think we could have
fur you know additional recommendations
for things to do um and there's always
next year but I think
um because I I think I think there's I
think also one of the things they asked
us to do is to see if there if there was
something we could combine so it might
be that we work on one but the other two
that are on the same subject right so I
could see that I think yeah there's two
or three that are on on one one yeah we
we could we could in fact it might be a
good idea
to consolidate and then retain the other
two for example that way that would give
us options um that's another possibility
um but I think yeah I think that's good
so um lots to think
about
um anyway all right um I will go around
the room at this point so we're getting
uh thank you all for your Indulgence
we're a few minutes over um but um let's
go around the room and I'll take any
final comments representative
Nome um I think today was a very
productive day um at least it felt that
way uh more so than uh it's always nice
to kind of move the thoughts and bills
and Concepts forward um instead of just
a day of getting information in that the
real synthesis of that was very helpful
and uh I think really moved the ball
forward quite a bit today and I
appreciate everyone's efforts thank
you thank you representative c um just
to re reiterate I think we did get some
organization here it I find it helpful
to have stuff on paper uh your four-page
list was very helpful in starting to
focus our uh attention on on the
particular aspects that that really need
to be uh
formalized thank you representative Lane
I would just Echo uh both represent
representative Nome and representative
C's comments I don't have anything to
add very good um I uh thank you I'm I I
do want to really help people focus in
on the issues so I'm glad that this has
been fruitful I I will just reiterate
that um I think some of my thinking
might may have been an error because
uh um there are certain aspects of the
national voter rights act that had been
referenced in other court cases and I
thought they could possibly extend but
as as representative Lynn former Chief
Justice clarified for us that that the
ACT is fully excludable to New Hampshire
because we still have maintained
that uh election day registration aspect
we haven't ever stopped it like Maine
did and then had to comply with both
aspects which um they clearly Maine did
not think that through
thoroughly um
and uh so I I think there's a lot of
rework that I have to do on page one
because the premises is um
is the problem statement is incorrect
um and so that that one aspect is not
something that we have to necessarily
comply and
then um there is there are aspects
where I think it's in Crawford versus
Maran but you know this the federal
government does have to defer to the
states for control of Elections and so
um that is something to consider so I
just bear in mind that page one will
certainly need a lot of
revision um I want to thank everybody
today for their contributions a lot of
thoughtful statements a lot of good um
analysis and
critiques of of everything was provided
and I think it's been good um really
appreciate the four meetings that we've
had so far hopefully uh we can do a wrap
up on Tuesday morning and
uh there's a lot of time or maybe not so
much time between now and then but we'll
see what we can do um again I think I'm
sort of looking at maybe
a 10 to 12 page Report
with maybe this as an attachment or
embedded Within that these may become
like figure ones if they're inside the
report or addendums if they're outside
the report we would also
include uh you know Mr Allen's uh memos
as well as the written testimony from Mr
Richard um and he is by the way he is we
gonna include all that no no we're not
going to include all the exhibit so we
we will make those available but not as
part of the report but I do want to I do
want to include his 14-page testimony as
part of the report so um because I think
it was it was
very his explanations were extremely
helpful and I think actually added on to
the Secretary of State statements about
the gaps in the absentee ballot his te
Mr Richard's testimony really helped me
think about that aspect much more
clearly and I
think um helped me understand the
affidavit um situation better and so I
think it's I think it's helpful if
we include that but not all the exhibits
but make the exhibits available as part
of the documentation received by the
committee all right any just final
comments yes sorry I just uh your
comments there made me uh just Jarred my
memory and I I sure hope we've said this
before but I'll say it again if we have
and uh I'd just like to get in the
record that to thank uh researcher Mr
Allen over there and all of his labors
and uh quick responses to all of our
questions and uh just thank you very
much for all your work
here yes fortunately you are paid more
than we are so
uh that
hiring are you hiring there you go um uh
very good yes um I think the whole
subcommittee Echoes uh what
representative Newsome we thanked you in
emails but for the public testimony we
we should thank you very much we we do
appreciate the diligent research and
it's been quite helpful so uh very
good um all right with that we will
adjourn the meeting and see you Tuesday
morning 9
o'clock all
right for